thank you Mr chair thank you members of
the committee uh for the record Jeff
Belanger director of planning and
Community Development for the city of
Manchester
um it's a pleasure to meet with all of
you I appreciate your time this morning
I appreciate the invitation from
representative long to be here uh my
understanding from speaking with him is
that this committee is interested in
learning about ways to address the
crisis of affordability that we have in
this state it's a laudable goal I
applaud that it's certainly something
that we are trying to do in Manchester
we're also working on dealing with
affordability of housing in our city and
so from speaking with representative
long I thought I would try to walk you
through a little bit about what we're
doing to try to help you understand how
we're working at the local level and
hopefully that can be of use to you so
if it's all right with you I've got a
written statement I'll just read from
that to give you a summary of what we're
doing and then I'd be happy to take any
questions that you might have so the
board of Mayor and Alderman and other
city leaders in Manchester have made
housing affordability a top policy
priority my department among others is
tasked with trying to find solutions to
make housing more affordable
something that I always try to keep in
mind for myself and something that I
frequently talk to policy makers about
in Manchester is that housing is subject
to the same Market forces of supply and
demand as all goods and services in our
economy and with the demand for housing
in Manchester continuing to increase and
costs continuing to go up my advice to
policy makers who want to bring down the
cost of housing is that we should be
doing what we can to add Supply we've
done that in Manchester in a number of
different ways first we try to create a
favorable regulatory environment for the
construction of housing we allow for
housing to be built densely both with
small lot requirements and by allowing
buildings to get fairly tall in some
areas we know that tall buildings aren't
for everyone though and so we try to
also find subtle ways to add to the
city's housing stock
for instance my department and the
Manchester planning board recently
worked together to propose a zoning
amendment that would allow accessory
dwelling units to be built more easily
additionally we hired a planning
consulting firm in 2019 to help us
rethink all of our land use regulations
and one of the main goals of this effort
is to create regulations that can help
add housing Supply and bring down costs
so as part of that effort we adopted a
new master plan in 2021 which
incidentally one plan of the Year from
the New Hampshire planners Association
and we are working on writing an
entirely new zoning ordinance based on
that plan
in addition to our written regulations
we also have a culture of being
favorable to development in Manchester
the planning department recently
analyzed the decisions of our Zoning
Board of adjustment from 2015 to 2021.
it was more than a thousand applications
and we found that the zoning board
granted complete approvals to 86 percent
of the applications that came before
them and partial approvals to another
three percent of the application so
that's close to a 90 percent rate of
saying yes when people who want to
develop their properties in ways that
don't quite fit with our zoning
ordinance uh come before them these
decisions by the zba are practical
decisions that tell us on the planning
staff that we need to reevaluate our
zoning ordinance and as I said we're
working on that now we intend for the
new ordinance to reduce the need for
applications to the zba in the first
place by allowing more development by
right but for now the zba is doing what
it can to allow people to develop their
properties
the benefit of Manchester's favorable
regulatory environment and practices is
that they allow us to respond to high
demand such as with the uh hot real
estate market that we're in right now in
the past three years our planning board
has approved around 1500 dwelling units
for construction in the city that's more
than double what we used to do during
similar time periods before the recent
spike in demand so to summarize this
first point creating favorable
regulations and having a favorable
culture is the first tool that we use to
add housing Supply and respond to Market
needs the second strategy that we use in
Manchester to try to address housing is
that we do our best to create
Partnerships with developers and other
private sector businesses to incentivize
the construction of housing especially
housing that is Affordable to people of
lower incomes for instance mayor Craig
created a housing task force that
included a range of private sector
representatives from our community that
task force issued a report in 2021 that
recommended the using city-owned land
for the construction of housing shortly
after the report came out the city
issued an RFP for the development of two
parking lots owned by the city in the
downtown we offered to sell the Lots at
low prices in exchange for requiring
developments that included affordable
housing we got great responses to the
RFP and I and other staff members have
been working closely with the winning
developer for the past couple of years
we recently got approvals from the
planning board and the zoning board for
construction to begin on one of the Lots
it's going to bring about 360 Apartments
to what was an underutilized parking lot
60 of the apartments would have rent
capped at 80 percent of area median
income and another 50 units would be
capped at 60 percent of area median
income it's also going to bring about
650 parking spaces in two separate
parking garages and we expect
construction for this project to begin
this year and we are continuing to make
progress on the development of the other
lot as well
the third strategy that we use to add
housing is that we take advantage of
outside funding whenever we can
Manchester is a HUD entitlement
Community which means that we get
federal funds each year to serve our
low-income population we're usually able
to allocate about seven hundred thousand
dollars of those funds each year to
incentivize affordable housing we try to
use those funds to leverage other funds
as much as possible we work with
non-profit partners that are great at
assembling funds from a variety of
sources and we try to fill in gaps in
their funds so that we can help them
bring affordable housing to Manchester
to give you a few quick examples in the
past couple of years we've used federal
funds to help with the construction of a
48-unit low-income development by the
Manchester Housing and Redevelopment
Authority we've helped neighbor Works
renovate and construct 101 units of
low-income housing we've helped a group
called Helping Hands renovate a property
to construct 11 single-family uh sorry
single room occupancy units and we've
helped families in transition both
renovated temporary shelter and
construct 14 units of low-income housing
Additionally the recent influx of arpa
dollars has created a unique opportunity
for us to incentivize affordable housing
even further we've used about 2.7
million dollars of arpa funds to help
with the construction of three buildings
from the same developer at one
intersection in Manchester these
buildings will house 192 Apartments all
of which will rent for 60 percent of
area median income or less
we also used about 1.1 million dollars
of pandemic relief funds to help
Waypoint renovate an old office building
that is now a youth homeless shelter and
three Apartments additionally we use
five hundred thousand dollars of Arbor
funds to assist the Manchester Housing
and Redevelopment authority to establish
a landlord incentive program which pays
landlords to bring their properties up
to HUD standards so that they can accept
housing Choice vouchers
these are just a few of the successes
but the point is that we try to work
with non-profit developers and service
providers to help them fill in the gaps
so that they can bring much needed
affordable housing to the city so to
recap we try to take advantage of
Regulation public-private Partnerships
and funding to help increase the supply
of housing in Manchester and bring
prices down
I recognize that I and my colleagues in
Manchester are working in a particular
context with a particular set of tools
that are available to municipalities and
may not translate entirely to the state
level of government so what I'd like to
do in conclusion is suggest that this
committee consider a fairly small
legislative change that may be able to
help bring down housing prices
as I said before increasing the supply
of housing means being able to build
more dwelling units per acre
problem is that it is really difficult
to get the kind of density that is
necessary to bring down prices when
housing is built without Municipal sewer
and water septic systems and Wells need
a lot of land per dwelling unit to work
so density needs Municipal Utilities as
I'm sure you know most municipalities in
New Hampshire don't have Municipal sewer
and water so their ability to increase
the supply of housing is limited my
suggestion then is that this committee
may want to consider a change to RSA
chapter 674 section 21 which is the
statute on Innovative land use controls
that statute allows municipalities to
charge impact fees to new developments
to help pay for infrastructure like
sewer and water systems
um
the issue with how the statute is
written currently is that it only allows
municipalities to hold on to impact
views for six years if the fee isn't
spent within six years it needs to go
back to the property owner when you
think about the complexity of planning
and constructing a municipal sewer or
water system and you think about the
tremendous expense of construction which
is usually bonded for something like 20
years you realize that six years is not
enough time to hold on to impact fees
municipalities cannot plan for a 20-year
Bond on just six years worth of
intermittent funds these funds only come
in when buildings are constructed so
it's impossible for municipalities to
plan for what's coming next
they need the money in the bank to
really plan and that money needs to stay
in the bank for a while uh so to close
this presentation on what I hope is a
helpful suggestion I would respectfully
suggest amending RSA 674 colon 21 to
allow municipalities to hold impact fees
for longer than six years I think 10
years might be on the low end of what
you might want to consider and 20 years
to match up with typical bonding
duration might be better doing this
would certainly help Manchester keep up
with our needs to improve our
infrastructure and continue to provide
housing and my guess is that it would
help a lot of smaller municipalities
have a good chance of creating their own
Sewer and Water Systems which would
expand the possibilities of warehousing
can be built in the state and therefore
bring down housing costs and so with
that I'll conclude and I'd be happy to
answer any questions
yeah we
thank you and thank you for your
presentation and I I appreciate it in
the from the outset the Nuance of you
mentioning the crisis of affordability
we normally talk about housing crisis in
general but
um
technically and this number may be just
a couple years old but uh you know we
have technically the number of rooms to
cover every every person in the state
the problem is they aren't affordable so
a lot of your solutions that you
proposed are um are helpful in concept
even if they you know not every
Community looks like Manchester I had a
question a specific question and I I
appreciate your very specific
recommendation I think it's a good one
um when you said uh rent caps on 80
median income and sixty percent median
income do you mean
those units were qualified for tenants
under that level or is that a price is
that like a percentage that is the rent
price
of so affordable for so 30 of 80 of the
median income is that what you mean okay
all right thank you I appreciate the
clarification
yes you you mentioned um uh
being open to finding outside funds
um and um I'll mention that um I'm
retired
retired employee of the U.S Department
of Housing and Urban Development uh
where I worked for 29 years
um but I retired seven years ago so I
won't ask you about any specific
programs because the programs change I'm
just wondering
um you said you're an entitlement
Community which in fact I know because
uh I oversaw a lot of that work
um uh so you're getting Community
Development block grant funds uh which
you're putting towards housing which I'm
very glad to hear
um can you tell me what other HUD
programs you've applied for and what
other HUD funding you received
uh you for the question specifically in
under our entitlement Community status
we get home funds cdbg funds and ESG
funds that's the kind of standard mix
that we get every year usually totals up
to about two and a half million dollars
um perhaps uh I know what home and ESG
funds are but perhaps everyone else
isn't quite as familiar so perhaps you
should tell them what that is sure home
funds are typically used for affordable
housing and that's when I listed that
700 000 number that's exclusively home
funds we also do use an additional we
get a hundred and sixty thousand dollars
approximately each year of ESG emergency
stabilization Grant funds those are used
also in a housing related context most
of the time we'll use them for what's
called tenant-based rental assistance we
will use them to to pay the rent for
people who cannot otherwise pay their
rents that's the standard mix that we
get every year on a yearly rotating
basis we also apply for other HUD funds
we recently got a healthy homes Grant of
about 2.2 million dollars and we also
got a lead abatement Grant so Manchester
as I'm sure you're probably all aware
has a very old housing stock about
two-thirds of our housing stock was
constructed prior to 1979 and 1978 was
when the the federal government passed
the law that requires all that eliminate
excuse me prohibits the use of lead
paint in buildings so we have most of
our housing stock was built before that
and so lead paint is a serious issue in
Manchester and so we routinely apply for
and receive grant funding from HUD to uh
uh to provide incentives to Abate uh
lead paint in rental housing
thank you sure
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um you in your opening you said
um
you were trying to make Adu acquisition
more easy in your um
in your zoning ordinance what specific
things are you trying to Target as far
as making that more easy sure and at
some point Mr chair I'd be happy to
invite our chair of a planning board up
as well he and I work closely together
on this whenever it's convenient to you
um but uh the planning department and
the planning board work together on
bringing a zoning Amendment to the board
of Mayor and Alderman uh for approval
and that's working its way through the
process now everything seems like it's
going favorably
um specifically that ordinance is
intended to allow accessory dwelling
units to be larger than they currently
are under our current ordinance allow
them to have lower setback requirements
so that they can be built in more places
on a lot have less parking requirements
right now it's one parking space per
bedroom and where the proposal is to
have just one parking space per Adu so
if it's a two bedroom it would still
require one parking space and maybe the
biggest thing is that it would no longer
require a conditional use permit for any
accessory dwelling unit that's
constructed in an existing building we
still thought that planning board would
want to have some jurisdiction over the
new construction of a new building in a
neighborhood but if it's uh which most
of them are the construction of an
accessory dwelling unit in an existing
garage or basement or addition to a
house or something like that the
planning board and the planning
department felt that it wasn't really
worth making the applicant go through
the process when there's going to be no
exterior change to the building
okay pretty interesting
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question it's simple what is the
increase in size proposed to be sure it
is currently limited to 750 square feet
which is uh per statute that's kind of I
think the minimum maximum that can be
put
um and so we're increasing it to 900
square feet
sure
thank you my colleagues are smiling at
me because I'm the prime sponsor of the
Adu bill which does much of what uh
you're talking about doing and we're
going to have my town planner come and
speak to us about edu's and what we're
doing in my town about that so I'm very
appreciative for all of that work
um I want to go back to regulation
because my experience of this committee
so far is that we seem to be more or
less on the same page when it comes to
ending a lot of exclusionary zoning
practices and stuff
um but we are less sure of where we are
as a committee on regulation
and when you talked about
um funds that your city gets one of the
things that I have seen in my town and
in other towns as well is and it's an
unfortunate term because it's confusing
but rent-thinking Behavior by landlords
who see that these funds are available
to tenants that they're getting
assistance and then raise their rents in
order to specifically exploit those
federal or federal or any kind of funds
that are available to them
have you found any way to prevent that
or regulate that
um we have not although I will say I'm
probably not the best person to answer
that because we receive the funds
ourselves we work with non-profit
Partners like neighbor works like the
Manchester housing Redevelopment
Authority they're the ones who tend to
administer those that New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority also so we
hope to provide the funds we work with
them but we are not in the kind of
direct landlord tenant link the way that
they are
sure
thank you for taking another question
um
when you are doing this kind of analysis
of the zba uh number of applicants how
how often they got approved did you also
look at
um like targeting specific sections that
seem to always be getting
um requests for zba
um or or was it kind of flat across the
whole zoning ordinance if you know and
then kind of what you you also talked
about trying to get a target of of just
lower I guess General applications to
the zba do you have like a specific
Target or or
um just can you expound on that I guess
sure so we did look into that we and
when you say specific sections I think
you mean of the zoning ordinance like
parking versus setback versus height
that kind of thing yes we did do that I
don't have the kind of results of that
analysis here in front of me certainly
parking was one that came up a lot um
you know Manchester has a number of
small lots a number of lots that are
arranged such that the house is pretty
close to the street and so when you try
to fit cars in a driveway it can pretty
quickly create problems for zoning
requirements because parking spaces have
certain Dimensions that need to fit in
order to comply with zoning
um setbacks was another one height not
as much this is kind of from memory so I
apologize but nothing really he jumped
out as glaringly more than anything else
but there were certain things that you
would expect to rise to the top like
those that I mentioned and and they did
but nothing was really a glaring red
flag I wouldn't think
so I mean I also asked about the like
the goal to that you're trying to reduce
you said like 1500
um applications I don't know if that was
that was over the entire period 2015
through 20 21 right they had 1100 total
applications uh and so thank you I
apologize remember this question now so
um we don't have a Target
um what we expect is that um as the
zoning ordinance catches up to kind of
what we can tell from the zoning board
and from other our experience is really
going on on the ground which is that the
zoning ordinance isn't quite reflecting
reality in all cases you know uh the
zoning board frequently will grant
variances for setbacks for instance and
it that is a clear indication to us that
the setbacks are probably just too big
and probably need to be reduced and once
we go through that exercise create the
new zoning ordinance that reduces the
setbacks we would expect a significant
number of fewer uh setback variances
being applied for we don't have kind of
like an arbitrary number not that's
arbitrary we don't have a number that
we're really shooting for but we would
expect just by common sense that would
come down significantly
I can follow up again follow up
um
yeah um
just to follow up on that
um
the
did you look at
um kind of
when you're looking at the zba kind of
variance opportunity
to to change the zoning did you look at
how many
um
things were or because of increased
zoning which made the existing
infrastructure on the lot
um illegal non-conforming yes
non-conforming um we didn't look at that
specifically our last zoning ordinance
before so the history of zoning in
Manchester is 1927 was the first one
then we have a new one in 1965 and then
the current one in 2001 and so we're
working on our fourth one now
um so it has been a long time between
1965 and 2001 and there are a number of
buildings in Manchester as you might
imagine because it's such an old city
that we're non-conforming on day one in
1965 and we're non-conforming on day one
in 2001.
um those are kind of part of the fabric
now uh and so if anything we are kind of
looking at as I said loosening the
regulations and trying to kind of roll
some of the restrictions back that were
imposed in 2001. Manchester a lot of
what people love about Manchester is the
oldest parts of the city and that's true
in a lot of cities throughout the
country in the world and so we want to
make those things that people love about
the city
um be legal and not be you know made
made non-conforming but be made
conforming because we would make the
regulations respond to what the fabric
of the community actually is
sure
what good green
referral Kella and I are just going to
play a little game of badminton here uh
so when when you're talking about how 90
of the variance is more or less are
being approved anyway and so can we roll
back some of those things do you have a
sense of how many people
might not be even applying because they
would have to apply for a variance and
so if that those ordinances didn't exist
you would have that much more
development and that much more Supply
being built it's a great question we
don't track that but anecdotally I know
that that's happening I've spoken to a
number of design professionals surveyors
Engineers we actually did as part of our
zoning process we did formal interviews
with a number of design Professionals in
our community and they told us that they
have lost clients because they have said
to them you know uh hey you're going to
need a variance to do this thing you
want to do but don't worry the
Manchester zba is usually pretty
favorable to this sort of thing so it'll
be a month and a little bit of money but
you know you'll get through it and the
clients say no thank you they say it
introduces risk and time into the
process that we as developers don't want
to deal with and we'll go somewhere else
so it's an unfortunate situation
whenever that happens because Manchester
loses out on the business or the housing
units that could have otherwise been
developed so that's certainly you know
the economic development side of this is
something that we take seriously and
we're trying to take into account as we
write our zoning organs and not a
question but I imagine a lot of those
people also they've had experiences with
other communities that weren't as
accommodating as Manchester has been and
so they've just kind of learned if
there's there's no point in fighting it
here okay thank you thank you for taking
my question so what happens when there
is a subdivision and there are minimum
lot sizes how does that work into
possibly having an Adu in a subdivision
sure so um that's certainly something
that can be accommodated in most
subdivisions and Manchester has a range
of lot sizes it goes up to 40 000 square
feet on the high end which is by New
Hampshire standards is actually still
not that big
um down to five thousand square feet for
a minimum which is quite Low by New
Hampshire standards but even in a 5 000
square foot lot depending on the size of
the building an Adu can be accommodated
and as I said earlier you know adus can
go in basements too they can go on top
of garages they can be pretty subtly
nestled into even a small lot and they
can fit
thank you follow-up but is there a
conflict with the covenants for the
subdivision like the subdivision says
you know you know uh
single family home minimum lot size two
acres blah blah blah how does that work
sure good question so um there are some
subdivisions where there will be deed
restrictions that are placed on it by
the developer we as the city of
Manchester don't regulate those so
that's a private Covenant in between
different landowners
um but um I don't I don't see I do
review a fair number of those I don't
see that as being a provision that I
frequently run into But ultimately it's
not a governmental issue so much as a
private issue thank you sure
okay
go ahead I want to follow up
to I just wanted to
um you mentioned one tool that you you
would uh like to see I was just
wondering if there was any other tools
that you may not be as as pinpointed but
just in the general scope of of
uh like you know I don't know Des needs
to update their you know rules or
something like that that could be more
vague but not as uh but still important
maybe I appreciate it I don't know that
I have anything fully formulated at this
point but I'll be happy to give it some
thought and get back to you yeah
okay follow up
we have plenty of time so thank you
again Mr chair and thank you again for
taking in another question so this may
be slightly out of the scope of your
your
um expertise because realizing
Manchester is obviously more more urban
um when you talked about uh development
and adus in particular being dependent
on the Water and Sewer requirements are
existing Adu statute of course still
allows municipalities to require even
off the water and sewer to require
appropriate
um water and sewer or water and uh and
septic
but a lot of those lot minimums I have
the sense might be again it's outside
Manchester five acre lot minimums we saw
a presentation in some communities
there's over 20 acre minimums clearly
you don't need 20 acres for uh for a
septic so do you have a sense of in
general and I know it depends on soils
and everything what kinds of size of
land would be appropriate for that what
would be like a minimum requirement in
general
I don't mean to dodge the question but
we we see uh septic systems so rarely in
Manchester so much of the city is on
Municipal sewer and water that it's and
as you say it is highly dependent on
soil types and a number of other things
so I I don't know that I should answer I
thought it might be outside your
expertise thank you well hold that
question we have an engineer coming in
on our next meeting so yeah I'm a very
well-known man in Manchester by the way
we have school vacation this week so a
couple people couldn't make it but he's
one of them
um
I know you anybody else boy I know that
uh Manchester uh Elm Street has got a
bunch of units uh planned now how far
did you go on loosening the parking
requirements for those
at least those two big projects on Elm
Street yep so
um when you see the two big projects you
mean the one opposite Market Basket yeah
one and then the one with the uh Pearl
Street yeah yep that one's just off
Manchester yeah so um both of those uh
buildings are in what we call the
central business district which in
Manchester has no parking requirements
you can build a 20-story building and
not put a parking space at all if you
want
so would you think that would be a good
idea for most cities to
if
it's so dependent on on the municipality
itself you know I mean that's that's a
CBD thing for us it's in a certain
District the rest of the city does have
parking minimums and we're looking at
those and how we can update them
um but you know it wouldn't be anything
that I would recommend you know at the
state level certainly that's that's
Community by Community you know okay
[Music]
um
anyone else
no oh thank you very much thank you you
have written testimony would you like to
leave that with us I'd be happy to sure
I can make copies and
this person yeah I have just one copy I
can yeah I can email it to you or I
could well if you want to leave it I'll
have copies made and get it to everyone
yeah okay if you want to stay uh with
them or you can go whatever either way
but I'll sit back here and they can come
up and uh
Brett you want to come up uh you want to
bring uh Matt with you you can
Brett Cowell is um
chairman of the planting wood and uh
that long is the automatic
representative on the planning board so
we know he wears several hats
representative for us to Alderman and
he's on the planning board so welcome
yeah thank you for having us so um just
for the record my name is Bryce kawu I
currently serve as the chair of the
Manchester planning board and I've been
on the board in general since early
2020.
and I'm uh representative Pat long uh
District 23 in Manchester and I also
serve on the board
I bet since 2006 uh other than two terms
yeah so um I have some testimony I also
have copies that I can hand out
afterwards but some of it was covered by
director Belanger so um he covered a lot
of things pretty thoroughly so I'll just
go through this and note when some other
things are redundant but I wanted to
First speak about some of the things
that we have done recently from a
planning board perspective to help
address the housing crisis in our
community and then get to some of the
areas where we could use your help I
tried to come up with some of some ideas
of
where some State action could be useful
for us so uh first of all we what have
we done on the planning board so in 2022
alone just last year we approved more
than a thousand units through the
planning board not everything in the
city that gets built has to go through
the planning board um but for what did
um to us we approved a substantial
portion of that and in my now into my
knowledge we haven't approved that many
housing units in recent memory
um and this year alone we're not halfway
through but we approved 427 units thus
far so we're doing our best to say
um yes and to development you know maybe
we need to have have some changes to the
application that's where the and comes
in but we try not to say no right off
the bat uh so it comes down to kind of
that culture director Belanger was
talking about we also uh the board has
tried to take a more active role in
shaping some of our regulations and
long-term planning for the city
um in the past
from my personal perspective I felt like
the planning board was being very
reactive and just handling the
applications that are sent before us but
in recent years we've really been trying
to say okay this is where the city's at
and this is where we need to be what can
we do to actually make a difference uh
from a more infrastructural standpoint
talking about regulations and all of
that so the Adu stuff that director
Belanger was talking about was very
important
um the vice chair on the planning board
took a really important role in
spearheading that one thing that um was
not mentioned is I believe the new
updates that are still being considered
by the board of Mayor and Alderman those
updates include allowing detached units
in the city
my understanding was that beforehand
they were not allowed maybe they could
have gotten a zoning variance but this
but but it should be a lot easier now to
build detached and then attached uh or
or like internal is more bite right now
so another thing is we tried to reduce
School impact fees for certain types of
developments that the data showed don't
post many school-aged children so for
example housing units less than 900
square uh square feet or having fewer
than two bedrooms those don't usually
have a lot of children yet we were
charging them a substantial amount of
money per unit which then when you have
a larger building that can be a lot of
funding that the developer would have to
come up with so
that was another one of the things
um I want to just briefly remark on two
other initiatives so one is that we're
updating or working to update that is
our City's bicycle master plan not every
Community has one but Manchester
developed one in 2016 and its goal is to
really help facilitate that other mode
of transportation and that actually does
relate to housing because there's
something that is an important indicator
for how affordable a city is and that's
the housing and transportation
affordability indicator housing plus
Transportation costs because if you you
know have to pay a 30-year income for
housing well a lot of people in a lot of
communities also need to have a car
which then can cost a substantial amount
as well for the payments the insurance
the gas so if we can allow some people
in the more dense central parts of our
city to get around safely and
efficiently with a bicycle if they don't
want to or can't afford a car that can
really substantially lower their total
housing and transportation cost burden
it also can make it less important for
us to ask developers to include parking
with their developments which we can
look at different types of parking
whether it's surface or structured but
structured parking can often cost around
twenty five thousand dollars per space
which when you then try to recoup the
cost through rent that can add a
significant amount and make it more
difficult to build affordability into
the development so the last thing about
what the planning board has been trying
to do is that we're trying to ensure
that we have a broad set of perspectives
represented on the board so there are a
few members who are in their 20s and 30s
so we're trying to bring that
generational diversity of perspective
some folks who are renters currently and
we're also trying to bring more racial
and ethnic diversity to the board
because Manchester is one of the more
diverse communities in the city so we
shouldn't be run just by you know A
specific group of people with a specific
background
um because we'll often miss things and I
know that I as a man has missed you know
I don't have any children I don't plan
to have any uh in the near future but
one of the members on our board is a
young mother and she has brought up
issues about access for things like
strollers and opportunity for kids to
potentially have a playground in an
apartment building and that is something
that I had neglected to think about
until we had her perspective so that's
part of why I think that's important and
something for other boards to consider
um so some of the things where the state
could potentially step in to help a bit
one of the things I want to talk about
just one aspect of direct assistance is
potentially allocating some more funding
for specific
development of housing for example the
invest New Hampshire grants that had
come out those were in my view pretty
helpful and then the city of Manchester
has taken the initiative to issue some
rfps itself if the state provided some
amount of funding it could make it a lot
easier for cities to say sure we'll
issue an RFP of our own and then we
could lock in some of that affordability
for some of the units but also get that
supply that we're really looking for
part of why I think it's important is
that you know new market rate housing is
really important for New Hampshire it's
an essential piece of the puzzle it
helps with our housing Supply helps you
know get some of that with minimal
government expenditure because private
developers are doing it it enables
filtering and then it also increases
competition in the marketplace but we
have to remember that the entirety of
the housing that we need is sort of on a
sliding scale from extremely luxurious
on one end to extremely affordable on
another end and at a certain point you
know there will be a point in the Middle
where a for-profit developer isn't
necessarily going to find the profit
that they're looking for to make it
worthwhile so it's great that they can
focus on the higher end developments
perfect for them and it's their right
and it does help the community in
general but it does leave certain
segments of our community in a bind
where folks
who oftentimes are really helping our
communities get going lower income
workers they can't afford some of the
newer development so that's where City
and state-led affordable funding
initiatives can help fill that Gap where
the market chooses not to so it's kind
of two parts one is allowing the market
to do more the other is okay well where
where are they kind of not focusing on
and what can we do on that front
um in terms of indirect assistance
director Belanger mentioned sewer and
water infrastructure I would
additionally encourage you to look at
potentially providing some sort of
incentive or funding from the state
level for communities to take advantage
of I think we could reflect on the
experience of hb44 where a lot of the
opposition did come down to folks
feeling uncomfortable with the sewer and
water infrastructure that might be
necessary you know they weren't sure who
would pay for it how would it get built
where would the money come from
um so
in Manchester we do have impact fees
that we could levy on some stuff I'm not
sure we've adopted sewer impact fees
specifically I know that developers
often help update some of the
infrastructure around them when they are
doing a development there are also user
fees so people who are putting you know
taking water in putting sore out they
they have to pay but
um in any case the state legislature
could step in either with education for
communities to help them see hey you can
pay for it by doing this or by removing
that concern entirely by saying hey
here's a pot of money and obviously
money isn't always the solution to all
the problems but if some folks are
worried that they can't afford to build
more housing because they can't afford
the sewer well that's one way to look at
it
um certain things that another thing
that could also be done is uh
prohibiting discrimination based on
housing Choice voucher status this
doesn't directly increase the amount of
Supply available but I think it's
important because the state government
does recognize that there is an
importance for people with housing
Choice vouchers to get housing like they
recognize that they desperately need it
they can't afford it necessarily on
their own but they are doing their best
to access the limited Supply we already
have and so I think if you know a
voucher holder finds a place that works
for them if they are otherwise qualified
then it actively works against New
Hampshire's interest if a private
landlord discriminates against a family
just because of some misconceptions
about what a voucher holder is like or
what they would need in terms of
regulatory
um like inspections and stuff like that
so we definitely we definitely need more
housing Supply but we really need to
stop sabotaging the folks who are trying
their best and have gone through the
process but then somehow get turned away
because there isn't you know because the
landlord can do that
so that's just a few examples of the
ways the the state could help and I'm
sure there are more Alderman long I love
her if he could share his insight as an
Alderman and also a member of the
planning board but that's what I wanted
to share off the bat so thank you for
listening
um so uh a bigger point I have but I
have a quick easy question and that is
you talked about bicycle plan
um which is great I'm just wondering and
I know kind of bicycle would be like the
low hanging fruit there but like has
that expanded into conversations about
walkability and I know you have
Manchester has some public
transportation but like making all of
that more robust yeah that's a great
question and that is in my opinion
that's absolutely where we should be
going I'm not privy to all the
conversations that are happening I know
that
um there are some parts of the city
where there have been conversations to
expand bicycle access build out a bike
lane
um by removing some of the street
parking or making travel go in One
Direction so you don't need as many you
know you don't need two lanes in each
Direction Just One leave One Direction
and I think there's been conversation
with the MTA Manchester transit
authority to make it a bus bike lane
that way they could run Transit down
that um Corridor as well so there are
discussions of that I know the um
Department not New Hampshire but the U.S
Department of Transportation just
released a new funding opportunity for I
think they call it safe streets for all
SS 4A and it's meant to be a
comprehensively enable municipalities to
take a comprehensive look at all of
those modes of transportation
walkability biking bus transportation or
whatever they have in addition to cars
um I don't know if Manchester is
planning to pursue that I would
encourage folks to uh in any Community
here to look at that but
um it's definitely part of the
conversation I don't think we have
any specific initiative on the planning
board to look at it holistically but I
would certainly welcome that opportunity
because I don't think we have to just
focus on bikes it's a big picture thing
okay thank you
um just uh for clarification
um you said you weren't sure
um whether Manchester had an impact fees
specifically directed to Water and Sewer
but I thought and maybe I misunderstood
but what I I thought what Mr Belanger
said was that Manchester does have
impact fees uh relating to Water and
Sewer but that you are concerned that
the city couldn't hold on to them long
enough uh because of the state statute
yep yeah I'll let uh director Belanger
answer that real quick thank you
thank you representative we do not
currently have impact views for sewer
and water I am in discussions with our
Department of Public Works about whether
that's going to be necessary given the
amount of development that we have
coming down the pike we want to make
sure that we're keeping up with the
infrastructure end of things as we
increase housing and business space in
the city
um my point was more just at a state
level it may be helpful for all
municipalities especially those that are
kind of getting close to the point where
they might want some Municipal sewer and
water but aren't there yet that um
allowing them to hang on to their impact
views for longer than six years would
help them plan that out and make a
better attempt at actually implementing
it so you don't have them but um
if you did have them uh or if another
municipality had them
um
it would be better if they could hold on
to them hold on to the money for longer
than six years yes I mean you can leave
the statute allows for any municipality
to use impact fees for sewer and water
so at any time
municipality has the authority to do it
it's just the amount of time that they
have to hang on to the fees is short
right now thank you thank you yeah thank
you director Blanchard and also uh we do
have fire and uh fire and school impact
fees currently so businesses and and uh
residential dwellings get charged a fire
impact fee um it's different for
commercial versus residential and the
residential units get charged for school
impact fee um but other than that we
don't have impact fees currently
um thank you uh yes I asked because
um uh
as as I expect to know
um uh House Bill 44 which was an infill
development Bill failed and it seemed
that a lot of the reason that it failed
was that people were concerned about
um uh whether there was enough uh
capacity in Municipal Water and Sewer
um uh infrastructure
in order to support four units where
there had been one before if if this
became common which the law uh under
house bill 44 would have allowed it to
do
um so I think you know that that is a
very important question
um and possibly more of an issue than
um say School impact fees because as as
you've pointed out uh not every
um not every unit will be occupied by a
family with children
um but every unit will use the water and
sewer system and the more units you have
uh the more pressure that puts on the
water and sewer system so that's
something you would always have to
consider I I would think yeah yeah
you're right on that and I think that's
something that this committee would need
to take in my taken under consideration
think about is there are different
routes he could take ranging from the
status quo to something more you know
significant but what do you want
communities to have to think about when
they're thinking about adding new
housing
it could be that you want to make it
clearer through education on what their
options are it could be that you want to
remove any possible concern entirely by
enabling communities to tap into some
sort of sewer and water funding it could
be something that I can't even think of
right now but I think that's part of
what this committee would need to
determine is we know we know where the
pressure points are but what are the
best ways to unlock the state's
potential for Housing Development
because we clearly haven't done enough
yet
thank you
um thank you for taking the question
um I
wanted to see about you mentioned bikes
I was interested in if you're have any
special regulation or differences in
your zoning or inner planning or thought
um
um directed towards
if if electric bikes one Wheels scooters
are going to be would be considered in
that also as far as like allowed in the
bike Lanes or are they going to be more
pushed in into the streets kind of a
thing as those electric type of
powered Things become more popular if
they are something that you guys are
going to be trying to filter into the
bike lane or outside
that's a great question I know that
we've been
bench and that has not always been
successful because we don't always have
roads that accommodate safe bike travel
so people will you know even if they
know you're not supposed to be on the
sidewalk if they feel if it's a choice
of being squished by a car versus riding
on a sidewalk they'll do that in terms
of what types of devices are allowed in
the bike Lanes I would have to defer um
to a member of City staff I don't know
if director blander knows the answer but
I don't think we actually have any
specific recommendations on that yet
it's really more of an issue that the
Department of Public Works handles
rather than the planning department I
don't I don't know if there's any kind
of additional lowered speed limit for
bike lanes that could be something that
that electric bikes could exceed but
that's really not mine thank you I've
seen some municipalities have have
restrictions of like even even like
walking a stroller across the street
would be not allowed in some
municipalities so it's very that they
can go outside of what I might see is
appropriate but
um what about uh min minimum like house
size have you seen like tiny home like
have you been able to
I guess there's now uh um zoning or not
a zoning but uh like a building code for
tiny homes and stuff like that do you
have
um minimum like house size requirements
in your zoning
um and what are if anything are you
trying to do to encourage those other
types of innovative kind of houses so
there was a fairly recent State
Amendment to the building code that kind
of made tiny homes just a little more
easy to build I mean things like you
know tiny homes can sometimes have Loft
space for beds things like that and the
building code as it was wasn't
particularly friendly toward that as a
general rule in Manchester there's no
minimum house size I mean you know a
tiny home can sometimes be something
that's on a on like a trailer or
something that's a different story but
as far as you know in New Hampshire you
need cross protection you need a
foundation right so
um as long as the house is built on a
foundation and meets kind of general you
know safety regulations for the building
code there's no minimum house size
okay
um
representative yokella may be interested
to know I've done a little bit of
research as part of a national caucus of
environmental legislators on the
different
um
categories of electric bicycle and it's
actually kind of become uniform across
the country anyway uh so this was a
question I was thinking of when the
director was speaking and then we kind
of went there again and I maybe more
formulated it the idea of water and
sewer impact fees in particular
forgive my ignorance but is there what
is the mechanism that enforces that to
be dedicated or is that something that a
municipality because if we're going to
like enshrine that for 20 years I think
what we would want to see in exchange is
to make sure that is going to water and
sewer and not like something that just
ends up in the general fund of the
municipality yeah absolutely um that and
I'll take that if that's okay yeah so
um the statute is written such that all
funds that come in for a particular
purpose have to be segregated for that
purpose and they are held in separate
accounts by the municipal finance
department to stay for that purpose so
the way that impacts these work just
generally is there will be a schedule in
the zoning ordinance and that schedule
will say based on square footage or
based on number of dwelling units how
much money needs to come in you know per
whatever the unit is and that has to be
segregated as I said for six years and
then if it's not spent it's returned
back to the person who paid it
um so it they so in Manchester we have
school impact fees we have fire impact
fees those are always segregated you
know there's no commandling of the funds
and they're kept for that purpose okay
sure
okay
yes representative thank you that's
actually a well maybe it's a question
I'm thinking about the probable
correlation between
the bypass the greater walkability
Etc
and retaining our younger populations
here or having those folks come back
after college or whatever they left for
I think that would be helpful in growing
our Workforce at the level we need it
yeah I don't know if you have any
specific data or if you all no longer
have seen that but I know several
different Studies have come out one of
them is by the statework play
organization and looking at what younger
folks are looking for
um and something that you know both
anecdotally as a younger person and with
some younger friends and also looking at
this data
um that really is something that the
younger Generations would like in
general is can I walk around my
community can I exist in these third
spaces in the community where I can just
be with my friends or even alone just
sitting enjoying a coffee or something
where I don't have to pay to exist you
know we have plenty of stores
restaurants where you can be there for a
time if you're a paying customer but
where can I just
actually exist that outdoor living room
so to speak that some of the the best
studies in the world have but maybe we
don't have enough of and some of the
folks who have that Mobility
in terms of being able to move around
because they have you know that
professional
um background or that education maybe
they're already out of the state and are
thinking to come back well what are they
going to look for and I think you're
right about some of some of that
equation for them is going to be
walkability bikeability or at least a
broader Choice range of choices and so
they aren't just pigeonholed
and I do want to pause here if I could
let uh Alderman long speak I don't know
if you had planned remarks but just
allow you to share some of your
perspective
I was uh I was just going to fall off I
mean both both of them did a great job
in articulating
what Manchester is currently doing uh we
pretty much take our lead from our
department heads
um I just uh with respect to the bike
Lanes there are no regulations uh the
issue we had when we first implemented
and were people in wheelchairs were
driving down Pike Lanes lanes and we
ought to let them know this is not for
you this is very dangerous you stick
with the sidewalk so that that went well
uh also the walkability the city of
Manchester was built walkable nuts
how was built all the Mills people walk
to the Mills so it'd be easier it seems
like it'd be easier to go back to
walkability but
conveniences with vehicles is is the
issue getting that you know having the
young people in downtown
um it's dangerous they're on their cell
phones there's there's bumper-to-bumper
traffic now that we've seen in the last
six seven years uh on the Main Street uh
consideration of shutting some of those
streets down
um is is considering that however the
businesses have an issue with no parking
um the two three spots they have in
front of their business they want that
for people apart in front of their
business so that's you know that that's
going to take a while uh to come down
um then the other thing was the
affordable housing
I remember in 2006 I was getting calls
from Bedford Auburn Hooksett looking for
people that needed Apartments
couldn't live in Auburn Bedford and
looks at I had relations there and I
would say yeah absolutely yeah I got a
place I could get them affordable
um you know now that
impossible for me even for people in
Manchester I used to have some companies
I would go to and they'd slide somebody
in that's the last couple years that's
been impossible
um they don't they just don't have the
places and also on affordable housing uh
what amazes me is that the minutes of is
that the developers from out of state
that know the paperwork
uh New Hampshire doesn't have
that other than your uh Manchester
Housing and Redevelopment authorities
they do the Section 8 Elder and disabled
um and you have neighborworks however
it's a little more expensive for them
because they don't manage their own
buildings these other developers that
are coming in the one we have with
woodio police station is in the law
office it's 100 affordable and it's uh
60 and under
um and and they're going to manage it
themselves so they don't have to
you know they they don't have that added
cost we also have a company out of
California that's looking to buy a hotel
and they have their own non-profits that
service those hotels uh with respect to
mental health and substance use so
there's a hotel they're looking at now
96 units uh to immediately get people
with those you know you know some of the
mental health people I talked to they
will never on their own be able to uh
take a step forward you know they're
they're going to constantly need
somebody visiting them on a regular
regular basis so so that's also being um
um you know that's also being looked at
uh
I mean I've spoken to developers uh they
came into us a major developer in the
city of Manchester uh probably about
eight years ago and I asked them what
what is it what's a unit cost and what
is it that you need to make it
affordable uh and at that time it was
180 000 and he says we need about
a cutting planning uh cutting zoning
we're just not going to come up with
100.
public money
to make that work and today I suspect
it's 250 to 280 are you
now building so
the also the um
yeah so a couple of ideas uh one of them
was my 79 email they got shot down and
you know I get that
um but it but I on a planning board
there was a business owner who came to
the planning board wanted to burn
building one of the
build a new four-story
she built a four-story she was a
restaurant
owners and they they were for her
workers to live there
uh and and once that was built it was a
cultural here a barber shop that opened
up next door in a cultural uh clothing
store and I thought
you know so here's the inner city
that we're spur and economic development
would would having you know would having
decent uh decent housing there uh so I
thought 79e going to anybody you know
that's that's a small uh something that
we could give somebody uh to because I
know that was very difficult for her to
get her financing she needed a couple
other investors uh
is highly
um so so that was that was one uh also
uh Manchester's doing density
people don't get refused
um so
with the density is there some way that
we could come up with inclusionaries
included in Arizona
with density for example
I you got 100 units you could put in
here you want 200. okay for that hundred
um for that hundred can we
can we get 20 affordable housing units
the developer could say no or they I
mean I spoke with what actually Brady
Sullivan Lodge developer and he said I I
don't do that paperwork it says well
you got triple the density in this one
building
I don't think 10 or 15 affordable
housing is going to break you
so you don't have to do the paperwork
you just commit to whatever 5 10 15 20
years that this apartment unit will be
affordable at thousand dollars a month
um for whatever whatever the time frame
is and if you if you can't
um you know and if you don't want to do
it at all uh then it's twenty five
hundred dollars per unit that we were
going to ask you to make affordable into
our Housing Trust Fund so that you know
the idea is keeping
our Housing Trust funding building up
you know two million dollars a year just
doesn't cut
uh to a people and and given us
affordable housing so how do we how do
we keep that building
um
and uh
I mean at the planning board level we
we even noted uh from the planning staff
that
subdivision development and it was a
recommendation if we moved things around
a little bit they would be able to in
Adu because right now in Manchester
we're looking at tight spaces they're
cram and in these units
it's okay with me you know as long as
there's
they're the market people if they
believe it's going to sell who am I to
tell them no make give them a little
more room you know this is your you know
and with respect to the parking downtown
there is no requirement uh and it amazed
me in the last six or seven years that
uh
young people don't even want to have
cars they want to bike they want to walk
to wherever the work is they want to
walk for entertainment
um so so that's that's an attraction uh
is to be somewhere as where I could go
to a baseball game go to the Palace
Theater go to you know go to restaurants
go to you know boards and Brews or
whatever
so
uh yeah so so so
having them you know having these added
small things with which the
municipalities could offer a developer
uh to to
you know bring bring a uh bring a
housing plan to fruition would would be
very
and and rents are just I mean we just
opened uh
it was a
ribbon cutting on Elm Street that was a
96th unit
96 units and you know they're looking
for twenty seven to three thousand a
month
in my head I'm thinking please don't
happen this I'm screwed big time if that
happens uh trying to hit people housing
but it may it that may be the market
sold so and you know you don't blame the
landlord I
it's a business
it's a business it's an investment
you know get your Market but you know I
get the calls from the elders have been
living somewhere for 30 years I gotta
leave uh I got to leave June 1st
there it's 900 a month going to 18. I
can't afford that uh so they're asking
me to leave
you know I used to be able to find them
places
however fortunately for the adus I have
been it's a couple of towns
I call I talked to their children and I
asked them if you know can you set up an
Adu for you know your 88 year old mother
um and it surprises me today that a lot
of people don't realize that statutorily
you have to you have to allow adus
you're just going to follow their
principles because because the two
different towns at their parent that the
children told me oh they're never going
to give me an inline
I've already tried that
then you know then I explained to them
it's it's required you just got to
follow their rules they were tickled
pink I wanted to do this for my mother
six years ago well you know so so the
words not completely out there that
adus are
are statutorily
yeah
that's it for me you too and you follow
thank you
um this question actually may go back to
director Belanger I'm not sure
um but
um uh it was brought to my mind by the
uh reference to uh older people
um having to move out of Apartments
where the rent is is increasing
drastically and
again goes back to HUD programs and this
uh the programs that I'm thinking of
um are generally uh we're a non-profit
organizations rather than cities uh
apply for the assistance
um but
um and I I I didn't ask about this
before because there were substantial
changes to these programs just about the
time I retired uh so I'm absolutely not
sure what exists now but there were HUD
programs that provided
um substantial assistance for building
housing for older people and or people
with disabilities
um and again those are generally uh
non-profit organizations that that apply
to those programs has a city of
Manchester have been able to work with
any
non-profit organizations uh to apply for
such programs as currently exists
I can't think of a project that we've
done that has been targeted specifically
toward you know Elder residents that's
typically as I said we use home funds we
use ESG for housing those don't have a
Target we haven't received that and it
could just be because our non-profit
partners are doing that entirely on
their own
um that certainly could be it just
um I guess I'm suggesting that that
would be something to look into the
programs were called
um for older people it was the section
202 program and for people with
disabilities in section 811 program
again there were substantial changes
just about the time I retired so
um you know I could I have it in my head
what it was before I retired but uh
unfortunately I don't have it in my head
what what it is today
um but this was something there was a
lot of activity in New Hampshire under
under both of those programs
um so that would be something to look
into in terms of uh what's available
today and particularly if um people are
being pushed out of apartments that they
can no longer afford we'll certainly
look into that thank you so just so on
the same on the same question uh we were
able with uh I believe it was home funds
or ESG with respect to mhra 48 units
uh yeah so so we get minimals we were
able to capitalize on that and get 48
more
um Section 8 or 30 30 Ami units but 48
is
in a month's time you probably got 30 40
people signing up for uh Section 8
Housing and it's a six to eight year
wait
believe me I know
thank you Mr chair
um Mr Belanger
um I worked for the Housing partnership
in Portsmouth a few years ago and we had
a an affordable housing development
there are actually two
houses
um in Farmington
the
the buildings
were going to be sold and we're building
a new development
um it was going to be
not Section 8 but it was it was going to
be a tax credit property and um so the
folks who lived in the affordable units
prior to the new construction were
entitled to the uniform relocation act
which meant that we had tenants who
um
who's whose income
was too high to relocate to the new
development and those folks got those
Ura funds have you read much of that
happening at all I have not heard that
happening but again we you know we kind
of
get the money from the federal
government we work with non-profit
Partners who are kind of the direct
interface with the tenants so our Pro
our partners may have heard of that but
that's not something that I've run into
I think it's something to look out to
look out for that if you know a building
is closing and it's going to be
redeveloped and there are federal funds
then the tenants who are being displaced
would be eligible for Ura funds we
actually had one tenant who
ended up with enough money for a down
payment on a house he got about
seventeen thousand dollars in Ura so
thank you
all right I want to apologize for being
late at a meeting but thank you
representative Rudy for taking over
um are there any other questions City
Manchester planning department thank you
for coming by the way I've been holding
mine back go ahead representative Rudy
okay and thank you Mr chairman I got a
couple of things
um
we're mentioning the cost of
construction for these new new homes and
building cost Iowa building costs our
labor costs are what labor cost is and
uh
trying to think of a way to lower
besides the impact fee is uh what about
the inspection fees now inspection fees
can be a little crazy too especially on
a big project
have you thought about when somebody
comes in you charge them one flat fee
and that covers all the inspections uh
just to relieve a little bit of their
cost on construction
uh we could certainly look into that we
actually do have a provision that was
enacted into our local building code a
few years ago in which
um if the any affordable unit you know
rent capped unit we we will defer
building inspection fees until
certificate of occupancy so that's you
know time is money for developers so
they get to hang on to that money for a
significantly longer period of time they
eventually do have to pay it but it is a
way to kind of defer that and allow them
to use that money for longer
um you know ultimately we want to make
sure that we cover our costs to the
extent that we can and that's what the
billing inspection fees are intended to
do but not not opposed to looking at it
further and taking suggestions about you
know how we could maybe trim costs but
we want to make sure that you know it's
if someone's paying the taxpayers are
paying or the developer is paying so we
need to balance that
okay well thank you for that and I
didn't expect to be talking about
bicycle Lanes today yeah
um and I wasn't really crazy about them
when they first went in because I almost
saw a couple of accidents because I
traveled Maple Street a lot and I saw a
couple pretty close calls
um but I was asked a question just the
other day I lived near the golf course
uh dairyfield and somebody asked me
about driving a golf course uh dear golf
cart
no
are the golf carts allowed in the
bicycle Lanes General and then also
besides that we have a former State Rep
who you can see all over town in her
wheelchair I've seen her with an
umbrella riding around in the rain and
she goes down Valley Street a lot now
and there's no sidewalk there so
wouldn't those bicycle Lanes be open to
those wheelchairs yeah that's a great
question generally if it's an internal
combustion engine vehicle no matter how
small usually those don't go in the bike
Lanes however you can look to some other
um countries that have done a lot more
with bicycle Lanes such as the
Netherlands and they have a lot of
accommodation for folks with different
abilities so if you have someone who
needs to get around in something
uh like that if if it doesn't belong on
the sidewalk but it would be dangerous
to be in the road then certainly there
are ways to accommodate them in a
bicycle travel Lane
um I think also it's important for us to
think about the the difference uh
different the different ways basically
that you could build a bicycle lane
sometimes when a municipality is first
starting out with constructing them
um perhaps with the Maple Street ones
I'm not sure what was the first in the
city of Manchester it's not always the
best design and so it requires the
mindset of being able to adapt and kind
of iterate on a design to improve it and
then eventually if it turns out that it
is an idea that the community is on
board with you can sometimes formalize
those painted bike Lanes with either
curbing or with something else
um obviously taking into account the
ability of the local departments to
manage it so for example DPW in
Manchester would need to be able to both
construct it and then also maintain it
through all four seasons and so that's
some something to consider as well but
ensuring the safety of everyone who uses
the roadway is really important we have
had deaths in Manchester on our streets
and it's nothing that you know we you
know you can't necessarily prevent
everything but there are certainly
things we could do to design our
roadways better in terms of how it ties
in with affordable housing and improving
the housing crisis again for me it comes
back down to how everything is related
and how the cost of building a
development might be tied in part to how
many parking parking spaces you're
requiring the developer to build and
then also will people who want to move
into this development be able to get
around if they don't have a car and if
the answer is no then automatically you
know let's say you're building a
three-bedroom apartment which we don't
necessarily have enough of in Manchester
well if you have three bedrooms you're
probably either going to have a family
or at least two roommates that means you
might have two cars if they don't have
another way to get around so it all kind
of relates obviously when you're
focusing directly on housing there are a
lot of different ways you could go but
it's just one thing that I think is
important to keep in mind okay one
follower okay thank you now
on the planning board and this happened
to me I
we sold a house
it was an extra lot with it but when we
looked at it it was just barely short of
a second building lot okay I mean like a
foot
and so I I took my client to the most
popular engineer in town and he says
you're a foot shot you're going to need
a variance well
all of a sudden I'll go through a
variance in a heavily populated area my
client figured it wasn't going to be
worth it it wasn't going to pass
if if I was a foot shot here
and I went in for a building permit and
the neighbor showed up and they said no
no no that lot's too small
how much weight do you put on the
neighbors
so as someone who serves on a board I
don't serve on the zoning board so I
don't know their exact thought process
but I know they have to meet five
criteria in terms of whether they
approve the variance or not
from the planning board perspective we
take all of the public comment um under
consideration and a Butter's concerns
are really important to us part of what
we do on the planning board is we try to
see how could we potentially mitigate
some of those concerns if it's a new
let's say there's a new restaurant
that's going in next to some residential
well if the abutters are concerned about
it being really noisy at night we can
talk with the developer and see okay
well what is the exact plan are there
certain hours of operation that you have
where would the you know would there be
any external speakers where would they
be pointed Etc et cetera there are
different things depending on the
development that you can do to make
everyone kind of
if not happy at least satisfied or
placated enough that where they're not
upset anymore
um but in the end it does also come down
to balancing the needs of the butters
with the needs of the general community
and also the property rights of the
folks who are bringing the application
forward so it's really hard to quantify
how important it is but we do take it
all under consideration okay yes well
this was a residential area and it was a
residential house with an extra lot so
it wasn't a change of use or anything it
was still going to be residential and it
was plenty of side yacht so
and I was just wondering under roll the
dice uh I wouldn't see much difficulty
uh getting that thrown to the current
boards that we have for the zba or the
not sure if it would need to come before
the planning board but as director
Belanger was noting before the the zba
in Manchester approves a substantial
portion of the applications that come
before it so as long as it wouldn't be
detrimental to the public in general and
wouldn't cause any sort of nuisance
which it sounds like it probably
wouldn't I would give it high odds of
success I mean I had good luck with
Manchester they think very good to work
with but this wasn't my dime I was
working with uh so the engineer kind of
discouraged them but because of the cost
and he couldn't guarantee anything so
anyway
um
if I I would like to personally thank
you guys for coming
um Manchester is my city and I'm very
proud of the way you guys act down there
and in doing business with you as well
I've had very good luck and you're very
Cooperative thank you thank you very
much thank you for coming thank you for
having us thank you
I'm glad to hear that uh maybe what's
not looking for gray-haired people
that's not a problem so
um right now I just want to take the
opportunity to welcome representative
Damon to the special committee on
housing
um I just got the appointment in my
inbox 30 minutes ago so welcome to the
committee um would you just like to
introduce yourself where you're from and
maybe uh what your interest in housing
is
thank you very much and thank you all
for letting me join an existing
operation uh so I'm a first-term rep
hope Damon Sullivan excuse me excuse me
do you have written testimony you'd like
to drop off okay yeah pass it around
thank you
I wanted that sorry no no that's good so
representative hope Damon Sullivan
County District 8 which are the nine
towns of Acworth Langdon lemster Goshen
Washington Springfield Sunapee my
hometown of Croydon and the City of
Claremont so there's a lot of diversity
in that area in terms of terrain and
density and Claremont has a severe
housing shortage I realize they're not
unique in that
um and Sullivan County is kind of the
Southern Tier of reasonable geography to
live in and commute to the Upper Valley
so I know Josh previously who's seed I'm
honored to fill spoke about the acute
housing needs for Dartmouth Hitchcock
and Dartmouth College and the other
a lot of startups up there and so forth
um
I've always been fascinated by housing
frankly my husband is a retired
residential building contractor so just
sort of immersed in
being associated with building processes
for many years
um
I have no background I'm a dietitian
diabetes educator by training I was a
small business owner for 37 years and
I'm just very interested in how we solve
this problem
so thank you thank you and welcome to
the committee
so so we have good if you're fascinated
with housing did you see the residential
units that Dartmouth Hitchcock put up a
few years back through a modulus yes
that's a company I'm a dealer for that
company oh wow that's awesome it's
amazing what they're doing they're
building hotels modular hotels
they're being very creative they're
attractive of course Attractive people
vary in what they think that is I think
they're attractive
um and there's just so much need
yeah and and I'm just one other piece
part of the reason why I was interested
in the conversation about cycling and
walkability
I have two adult daughters who live in
New York City
and clearly a very very different
environment than a city the size of
Manchester
but even on a lesser scale looking at
the way other communities have evolved
to go from being completely car Centric
to you can safely bike most of New York
and it's the fastest way to get anywhere
so it's very appealing to people who
want efficiency and fitness and cheap
and I think it's something we should
definitely continue to consider
great so we have um 30 minutes or so
because one of our appointments canceled
so
um I published that we'll have work
sessions immediately following
presentations so we're following a
presentation so I I kind of want to just
open this up to the committee um we've
heard if you've sat in from day one or
whatever there's been a lot that we've
heard from various stakeholders I'm
looking at
um a document that I forwarded to the
committee from housing action New
Hampshire which
I would say pretty
accurately sums up
things that we are looking at in this
committee I think all of these points
are things that we brought up as
concerns so I kind of want to open it up
to the committee
um our charge is to come up with
prospective legislation moving forward
so
um who wants to start
representative well thank you but
um I want I wanted to
um it's
uh kind of touch on number three and
just talk about see if if we like it's
talking about you know proposed
legislation about Des
um
I'm just wondering if we can just get
Das in here and have them tell us what
this this so that we wouldn't actually
have a committee and then we can just
solve that you know
theoretically solve it sooner than later
if if they can answer all the questions
and if they can't then then we could
possibly have some proposed legislation
to study it further
yeah I agree with that I know there was
um some housing units in Goffstown that
came up with a snag um through it it
some breakdown in negotiations with Des
so I totally understand that
um so I will be reaching out to that
department and get them in here so we
can talk to them
I'm glad your mic's not on for that
but that that is a very good idea
uh representative Reed yeah
atus oh my God oh my God it is so we
heard I think from every single person
that spoke and and for multiple people
who spoke previously about adus as you
know I love my bill very much
um which we we tabled specifically so
that this committee could work on it
um for those of you who aren't familiar
I was wondering if the chair thought
it'd be appropriate for me to kind of go
what's in the the bill that I had
written and then like use that as a
launching place but I presume not
everybody's familiar with the more
nuanced details of that representative
Yokel looks like he has an opinion
your mouth was open I would say yes
let's look at look at that and then
um there's other things in adus I was
concerned like when a municipality
allows any
right
that's something we need to it so why
don't we start a blueprint we we can
start with Adu seems like the place that
the majority of the committee is kind of
consensus on it I I was planning on
getting printouts of the hb423 for our
work session today at three o'clock but
I didn't know if
um people wanted me to just talk about
that then or like give you kind of like
the the highlights of of that now
because so much of what was said today
like was already in 423
I think that
um I would prefer to wait until three to
discuss your
um
moving to two
um adus what I would like to talk about
is thing like right now given that we
don't have that language in front of us
is to talk about some of the things that
maybe we identified that could be
improved with the existing Adu
rules as far as you know something like
Joe was talking about with the parking
parking is um you know changing the
parking
um requirements and the existing Adu
area
um changing
I would like to see
the um a change to uh detached being
defined kind of like how you were
defining it as far as whether that
whether we add an additional Adu
to that or in the first Adu just having
um adus be uh
uh allowed to be inside of existing
structures per by right and not have
what I would like to see representative
you're saying exactly the stuff that I
was about to say because a lot of 423
was dealing with the first uh the first
or the existing buy right Adu so in
expanding those definitions and
increasing the size and things like that
I think that what I would like to see is
um
kind of like what what
um Manchester was saying where if you
have the Adu being put in the ZX inside
an existing structure
um that you do that it is by writing you
don't have to go to like especially
you're stealing my thunder that's so so
for those of you who aren't familiar
with the bill
um part of what I wanted to say was and
and part of the the where I got the idea
of putting in this bill
um was that the current buy right
statute allows towns to restrict that by
right Adu to attached only meaning
attached to the primary
um unit and I had constituents who had a
pre-existing already approved by the
town uh detached garage so you're not
increasing any footprint everything is
already you know copacetic and yet the
town decided to use their ability to
interpret that definition of attached is
you know not inclusive of completely
contained with any pre-existing detached
structure and prevent these people from
putting an Adu for their mother-in-law
in that detached garage so 423 does
change that definition expands the it
allows the second one of the two ideas
to be detached by right but it's spans
the definition of even attached to
include completely contained within a a
technically detached but pre-existing
structure because the idea is you're not
building an apartment building in your
backyard it's a garage it's still a
garage it's just now it has a person
living in it so do we have broad
consensus that that's something that the
committee wants to move forward with
is there anybody that disagrees with
that language
I'd like to look at it but it sounds
good okay
sure representative Reed can you bring
in that language that's I was going to
have them printed over lunch so we have
it ready for three o'clock and we are
going to hear I believe from Newmarket
Town planner who was helpful in in
helping me write the bill and also the
Durham Town planner helped as well the
other thing that I did was allowing the
one of those two units there's a lot of
things that 423 does but one of those
two units to go up to a thousand square
feet right now towns can restrict it
down to 750 and the idea is that if we
want housing to not just be affordable
but sustainable like as in it's not just
for a college student or you know a
single person or whatever but people can
have you know start families in these
things and actually use them as
long-term housing that really 750 is a
bit too small for a lot of people
so okay representative Gibbs uh thank
you
um just a few things Beyond uh adus and
this is not not necessarily in the order
in which I recommend them I just I just
put them down in my notes
um uh one is that I'd like to look again
at infill housing Beyond adus I was
honestly very disappointed
um at the failure of House Bill 44
um and I think that there are
um uh things that can be worked on there
um another is
obviously and I think we're mostly on
the same page on this
um is questions of zoning
um uh specifically lot size requirements
um some of which
um
seemed to me to be beyond the realm of
reality although I do think we need to
hear from the engineers regarding uh
what's necessary for a septic system
honestly I grew up with a septic system
um but
um I was a kid and my father was very
good with these things and and
um so he dealt with them and nobody ever
explained to me how they actually uh how
they actually worked with what the
requirements were
um so that's obviously something that we
do need to understand then more
generally uh the need for water and
sewer and I think perhaps the need for
some assistance to municipalities
um in improving their water and sewer
systems or in
um uh being able to use dedicated impact
fees uh to address those issues so those
are are obviously serious issues uh but
there there should be ways to address
them rather than just saying no
um which a lot of people have been
saying to me and I I don't accept that
um and then the last thing is um I was
very interested in the presentation
um from the city of Dover on transfer of
development rights and I haven't really
they sent us something I haven't really
had had time to go into it
um but I think that's uh probably
something that we should at least think
about
um so those are the things that I I
think we should look at Beyond adus
representative Wallace thank you um
I agree with everything that's being put
forth here at this point in time I think
we've identified a couple of different
groups of action on action items I would
say the adus is probably like a low
hanging fruit uh we've already got some
groundwork established there we can all
get on the same page we probably have
some other subjects that may take a
little bit longer to get done but we may
be able to get almost like an Omnibus
build together and maybe get a couple of
things that don't need a lot of work
put together agreed upon in a rapid
fashion I've already got something in
with OLS along these regulation areas we
might be able to get this done rapidly
and have it go on as a trailer to the
budget we know the governor is on board
with getting these types of things done
done
yes getting these types of things done
and a couple of small steps would
certainly get us you know we're heading
right for the End Zone
um and uh all of these things can be
done I think we shouldn't
leave the adus only to the cities in the
rural areas where people have sufficient
uh lot size which would support an
additional leech field I do have a bit
of a background on this but if you've
got a you know a five acre lot or
something like that you might be able to
have a detached
um additional dwelling unit and another
small leach field for your mother-in-law
or anything like that
exactly and let's face it I think the
bulk of the people that are desirous of
adding additional dwelling units to
their properties are for the the
Mother-in-law the father-in-law the
recently divorced daughter or offspring
something like that and are likely to
not need an additional parking spot so
those are going to be crucial right the
things to have worked in
approach like this
we're not going to get the 20 000 units
we need in a year but we're certainly
going to get the horses running on the
track in Rapid fashion I I completely
agree and that much of what you said is
it was the point of the original bill
um the difference of course just to be
clear between hb44 which is the four
Plex and the two main differences
um other than the fact that Adu has a
technically smaller you know not the
primary but the main differences are
hb44 is specific to City Water and Sewer
areas and it allows developers to do
that to build these multiplexes
um and adus are only for owner occupiers
to build now they can sell and someone
can buy it but only owner occupiers can
build adus currently and I did not
change that in the bill I wanted to ask
if everybody on the committee and maybe
this is the chair's job to ask like what
do people think of the director's
recommendation about extending the
impact fees and holding them for 20
years is that something people thought
good about
yeah I think that makes a lot of sense
only because when you're looking down
the road like the financing or whatever
that'll help and those funds will be
available for
maybe not 20 years but you know 10 yeah
you're there and it you know because I
know Builders have a way of doing things
and then running away so yes I do but to
keep the funds I think that only makes a
lot of sense and it makes it makes the
process easier for the municipality too
because it strikes me as the kind of
thing we could slip into
an Omnibus like you know thing I
hesitate to do
it I
I think that we should move forward as a
committee
in September the proper channels allow
vetting of all of our bills in
committees that
um are not this one
um but I I think I want to see multiple
bills as regard instead of one bill
because it's easier to
for an idea to fail if it's one big idea
then 12 small ideas so I think we should
think small and I'm an incrementalist in
policy I don't try to over over extend
everything I'm still partial to
representative Wallace wanting to like
just get something in now I know let's
do something now yeah appreciate that
um the the one difference
that I would say is that there are a
couple of bills that have already had
some public hearings and maybe those
ought to be brought to the front of the
pack and maybe not weight to it so
remember if we can have a you know a
Germain Amendment somewheres
um you know yeah Budget Trailer bill
um
I think there's some simple low-hanging
fruit that might not require as much
yeah valid point the Optics of it if we
delay on this this committee was formed
to make some uh you know good analysis
and make some recommendations because
this isn't a new problem so you know
putting that pause button even if it's
only for a couple of months yeah the
objects might not be the best
right representative Damon
just throw your mic on for it a couple
different things
um
it seems like there could be a middle
ground between
maybe not an omni bus bill but saying
what could we accomplish a handful of
imminently even if it's just small
impact at least as a step in the right
direction
and building support for working on this
problem I'm sorry to harp on this please
talk into the mic
you can move it you know
yeah how's that
is that better
um so oh that's much better thank you
but overall I do agree that
we should do this deliberately I'm
frankly not a huge fan of attaching
everything to the budget bill I don't
think it's a good process good democracy
if you will
separately
and I noted one of the speakers this
morning commented on this
we need an education or PR campaign on
adus
because I think in the rural areas also
there are loads of opportunities for
them to be developed and they're just
not on people's radar at all
um so I think looking at who would be
responsible for that and what kind of
funding would it take to Simply Market
to the public you can do this
it's not an immediate impact not
everybody's going to jump on it but I
think it would be valuable
oh and also and this comes from
working on education committee
whatever we could collaboratively do to
increase the labor for building through
our CTE schools maybe through some sort
of partnership or credit arrangement
with developers I mean we
part of the crisis is we don't have the
people to do the building work
I know representative
representative
Mr chair I don't know a lot about water
and sewer impact fees and I did notice
that it was suggested that those fees be
held on reserve instead of like in an
account but I also wonder about the the
uh inflation Factor on those funds I
mean how do you
let's say it's you know your water your
impact fee is ten thousand dollars now
and you sit you're putting it in reserve
your pattern numbers are for 10 years
how much is it going to be worth in 10
years so how do you how do you keep
increasing and make making sure that the
yield is more
okay
um representative yokella then
representative Gibbs
does anyone have an answer
well I was just going I think they put
in a savings account yeah but
um
yeah I think so
um one thing that I think that is
um
not on adus but is low hanging fruit is
to
um is we just as the the people in
Manchester said we just adopted this new
um
zoning that allows for tiny homes and
that are not zoning this uh building
code that allows for tiny homes but some
of the municipalities because we didn't
have that infra that that opportunity
previously had set many many uh lot or
uh house size requirements
and I don't believe those now that we
have this tiny home
um building code are appropriate anymore
and so I would like to see a no minimum
size house size
um
uh record like past you know Statewide
just as we passed this new zoning or
this new
um building code to accommodate those
smaller types of homes that those be
able to be built because in
municipalities like
the one I'm in had
something saying you can't you have to
build 600 square feet and when I went to
my town and asked them why they were
just like this is how it always has been
even though now we have
um uh building codes that would allow
for smaller houses to be built safely
and and appropriately so
um and I was thinking about as far as
like the funding for water and sewer I
think that if the state was encouraging
either give
maybe utilizing the um the Housing
Authority that that loans out money
um if they were able to loan out money
or give you know municipalities
um a better uh
opportunities for investing in that that
sewer infrastructure
um that we put strings attached that
they have smaller lot size requirements
on all of those all of the Lots attached
to any of those
um monies that we helped
not that we're giving the money away
necessarily but even if we did give the
money away but if if
um
we just give them a better interest rate
or whatever then we tied some strings
onto that for at least the life of you
know the loan the loan or whatever that
they have to have you know lot
requirements that are
and I'd also like to see from Des them
have a specific like you know grade of
ground equals this many lot or this many
bedrooms so that we as a state can say
what is reasonable and what is not
reasonable if we even do something on
the outside of saying
double you can do double the amount of
requirement that that it requires for
for the ground to be able to Leach on
these things that are not attached to
water and septic but over double is just
overreach and and is no longer
appropriate something along those lines
I would like to see you know a lot of
the people in in Municipal and County
government they were worried about like
what is going on with you know why
aren't adus actually being used some of
that is education some of them is the
the current regulations being
um limiting detached and limiting the
size and limiting all of these things
and so adding an additional Adu doesn't
really help if you can't get the first
one because of all of these restrictions
and then there's also kind of like the
the concern from Municipal and County if
you're if you're planning to spend them
send them through their normal
committees that they're going to be like
well
why is why should we be forcing this
municipality to do it this way and I
know in my community one of the
communities that I represent that
they're like I don't want you to
override us because we are doing
something like this where we're saying
you know for Wetlands if you have a
wetland setback based on your soil type
if the soil type is X you have this much
Wetland set back if you have it this you
have a different setback and they don't
want overruling on that but I think that
we should be encouraging more of that
like fact-based
um zoning instead of arbitrary two acre
five acre 10 acre whatever and I also
like the idea of you know
um putting
putting these
um saying that you can't forbid you know
things that are already existing
especially like your historic district
that you say that you love this historic
district but then you make it illegal I
think those things are low-hanging fruit
that this this this committee may be
able to get the Senate on board and
Pitch them the idea and if they like it
they can put it in the budget it's on
them it's not on us right we are just
the house we don't we could we already
passed the budget what are we going to
add a trailer bill on right we just
pitch it to the to the Senate and they
add it right and so it's not necessarily
on us I don't think okay I'm gonna go um
representative Gibbs and representative
thank you
um back to representative DiLorenzo's
point about
um uh impact holding on to impact fees
and inflation
um I mean there's no there's never a
perfect answer to questions about
inflation uh but you also can't predict
how much inflation there's going to be
in the future
um I mean there have been periods of
time when it's been very low other
periods when it's been high so you can't
predict how that's going to affect it
and in any case
um right now uh if I understood
correctly
um
the city
um Can Only Hold On To the funds for six
years
um so if the question is between being
able to hold on to the funds for 10 or
15 years and having it having the amount
of money being worth a little less and
having to give it all back after six
years if you haven't quite been able to
um work out all the economic and
bureaucratic ramifications of how to use
the funds
um the city will be better off uh being
able to use it uh after 10 years
even if it's worth a little bit less so
I think that's worth doing even if we
can't completely account for inflation
I agree with that uh representative Reed
no just there's so many things to
respond to now
one would hope that the city could like
do CDs or something if they know that
they have it for a certain number of
years and that that interest that they
would be getting at the end of those CDs
would hopefully account for inflation
yeah okay so back to everything that
representative yokella said like I know
I don't want to scare representative
yokella but we are of the same mind on
all of those points
um
um so I had actually already written in
my own notes to tie lot minimum sizes to
what the water and septic was capable of
in some way shape or form like you said
it could be double or whatever but
making that proportional and the reason
I we we had a few weeks ago a
presentation where we were told the
history of these kind of zoning
ordinances and how it all originally
came back to health safety and Welfare
of the people and how that mission creep
had moved so far afield over the last
hundred years to where now it's like
well we really like 20 acre minimums or
we really like 4 000 square foot homes
and and to the tiny home I want to make
a a public commitment right now to help
representative yokila with any bill that
will remove the square foot minimums
from buildings or from houses in
particular and also I think bedroom
requirements because as the Director
said there was like Loft you know like
that wasn't considered a bedroom and so
wouldn't be allowed but removing that as
well because again it has to go back to
health safety and Welfare and if it's
safe for someone to live in then it
should be permissible and it shouldn't
be up to
um the the NIMBY effect
um and then something that
representative Damon said about the
education piece and I think
representative basically answered it for
me so yes you know having education
around adus is great but I think one of
the reasons that people aren't doing it
now isn't even so much the education
piece as it is that they are currently
restricted from being able to take
advantage of their right to build that
first Adu by right because of the
detached and because of the the the size
and all the other restrictions in the
parking that that municipalities are
allowed to put on that so changing that
will not only open the door for the
first Adu but also for the second so I
think I got through most of everything I
hadn't stored up
okay um representative Wallace thank you
and just to address the the septic uh
leech rate issue um every single septic
system that's designed and approved in
the state of New Hampshire at this point
in time has its own file and the
particulars to that Leach rate the type
of soils there's about 15 or 20
different types so what I'm driving at
is it's not going to be a a linear
equation if you will that if you've got
a three three bedroom approved septic
that you can go double that that's going
to be a function of the types of soils
proximity to Wetlands and things like
that so that's going to be a little bit
different than in a city with city sewer
where you can just look at the flow
rates of the whole system just something
to consider okay representative I I
thank you I just wanted to respond to
that I was trying to tie the lot size
requirement to the to the soil type not
the actual like how many bedrooms you
could have per per uh like leach field
or whatever that
um
kind of
trying to
um so what I'm trying to drive at is on
the municipal and County government
committee they are
they much more prefer to have latitude
as far as local municipalities being
able to
um
do adjust some things and so what I
think is the best way to approach it is
to say no we're not mandating you do
something we're putting up guard rails
for these are the appropriate areas for
which you to have your flexibility
but 20 acre lot requirement is not
flexible that is unreasonable and where
is that guideline or where is that that
threshold I think that Des could help us
say like hey for this type of soil
um requiring two acres makes sense for
this type of soil requiring five acres
doesn't make sense you know that kind of
thing and then maybe even have a
um some type of uh
function where they have they in the
municipality that you can come and say
hey my soil type is actually something
other than my zone or whatever that or
doesn't fall in this
um normal range uh you know you can go
to the go to
um maybe the zba or something and say
hey my soil type is just on the
borderline or whatever can I have it be
in this one
um versus that one because I'm only
planning I'm I I'm going to you know do
a smaller lot size but I'm also going to
you know put in my deed that I'm only
going to have three bedrooms Max on this
property instead of
you know unlimited which is the normal
amount right and so that you can come in
and do that kind of negotiation with
your soil type coming in saying that
this is what Des says is like the what
they recommend as maximum or the minimum
and then you know I think that's
generally what DH is coming up and
saying so I'm thinking like legislative
are you saying
um
like Min
a minimum lot size no greater than 25
more than what the Des recommendation or
something like that sort of language
right so I would I would like giving the
flexibility right absolutely absolutely
so Des comes in says like you know soil
type one has can support three bedrooms
per thousand square feet or something
like that and we say okay you the
municipality can limit that to 1.5 per
thousand square feet or something like
that and
um
so you're less doing it on on size but
instead on per unit because really
the the municipality I've there the
reason why we're limiting it is I think
that if you want to have you know uh 20
acres or whatever you could put a bunch
of units on that or if you want to have
a small lot with one one
you know home or one room
then why can you do that right one
bedroom it makes more sense
I I understand the wanting to do the
bedroom but I'm concerned that
municipalities may see that as like more
of an overreach than going to just like
no greater than like a certain
percentage of like a minimum lot like
that that the soil can sustain right
because we want to create a like options
for them but not like limit it to like
bedroom like have like four bedrooms
right that's um representative Gibbs
thank you
um a couple of things
um first of all
rather than the specifics isn't the
point really that we want the
requirements to be evidence-based rather
than arbitrary which is what they
frequently are now
um somebody says well we think there
should be this amount of of space
between houses and so that's what got
written into the law 30 years ago and
it's still there
um but rather you're talking about
evidence-based in terms of what the
engineers can tell us is actually needed
in certain soil types of certain types
of septic system that makes sense
um it also makes sense to me to provide
some options
um that's always a good idea uh but then
the second point is
um although the municipalities
um uh are certainly going to object if
they see us mandating uh certain things
even so don't we as legislators have a
responsibility to the state sorry to the
state overall uh that we know that the
state has a housing shortage problem a
serious housing shortage problem where
organizations that need to hire workers
can't hire workers because those workers
can't find an affordable place to live
and as a previous presentation uh was
telling us uh people whose rents are
being increased have to move but they
can't find a place to move because they
can't find an affordable place to live
and we as legislators have
responsibilities to deal with those
problems even if that means being a
little more mandatory than certainly
some of the municipalities would like
okay so just to sum sum this up I'm
seeing adus as an area
I'm seeing Des soil types so this so one
of the next meetings needs to be with
the with des and then I'm also seeing
to get some back Base information
regarding soil types and um I'm also
seeing
um code building codes and code
enforcement we're going to hear from
Bill McKinney after lunch about building
code in code enforcement and inspections
so
I that's like kind of three buckets do
we see like we're gonna go for lunch now
but do we see any other kind of subject
areas that you'd like to talk about at
three o'clock representative
I never saw that before
um
so there may be some prior discussion of
this that I'm not aware of yet I haven't
finished watching the second half of uh
February meeting yet
but I know in Sunapee and some of the
other communities there's a significant
issue with airbnbs taking over what were
Residential Properties has that been
discussed
I know there's I know there's
legislation in the Senate I believe or
there was legislation I'm sure I'm sure
representative Reed would be able to
tell us about that but
um
it's something we can look at for sure I
know that's an issue especially in
Conway and other areas of the state yeah
so last term there was a bill and oh boy
Airbnb since uh yeah so some some some
some high dollar lobbyists
um in the Adu build this was pointed out
it's like well what if people start to
build adus just for airbnbs and that's
not what we want we want housing
um so in the bill and this is what I
worked very very closely with the
municipal Association on
um there is the ability to restrict the
second and it doesn't it's not
chronologically this second is if you
have two adus one of them the town can
restrict that to a certain rental level
and D so a that helps as in affordable
um and a that helps get to affordability
and it's wonderful because the people
who are doing this are owner occupiers
so they're not like as driven to get
like high profit return as a developer
is so they're just looking to defray
some of their mortgage but then the
other thing is what that does is in
effect it prevents the the Airbnb
problem because if you get that level of
income if you average out that nightly
amount that you'd be getting would be
way more than what the Restriction would
be and so
um without actually going into
short-term rentals which I didn't want
to do in the bill because I knew I would
get all these Airbnb lobbies come
flooding Concord
um we were able to kind of skirt that
problem by saying this is a way by
making it affordable just one of the
second I didn't want to touch the first
Adu at all I wanted to leave all of the
rights and expand the rights for the
first Adu but for a second Adu
um by doing that we get we negate the
um drive for people to build adus for
for short-term rentals okay um I'm gonna
let representative Damon have the last
say and then we'll go to lunch so just a
quick response I appreciate that and it
makes great sense for the adus
but what I'm also aware of is
buildings that were four to six
apartments that are now completely
Airbnb and therefore no longer available
as residential property so I think
that's a separate piece with lots of
lobbyists involved
thank you all right um we're going to
break until one o'clock thank you
all right this is a committee on housing
we are going to have a little delay
where we've got a technical problem with
the
equipment we brought in
all right it's uh 108 p.m a special
committee on housing I want to welcome
um a friend of mine Bill McKinney from
the New Hampshire building officials
Association thanks for coming Bill uh
we're excited to get your expertise on
building code and what your what your uh
Association deals with so thanks for
coming
oh just put your mic on for us thank you
thank you uh chairman Alexander and
Representatives committee thank you for
uh inviting me today I'm Bill McKinney
I'm the current president of the New
Hampshire building officials Association
I'm also the chairman of ICC
International Code Council region 6
which represents all of New England and
New York
um I am also the building official for
the city of Nashua New Hampshire
so
in conversations with
um representative Alexander he asked a
little bit about what the building
officials did what we do for the for our
organization what our organization does
for code officials in the state and what
are what are we focusing on as far as
some of the affordable housing issues
that are going on in New Hampshire so a
little bit about New Hampshire building
officials Association or nhboa which
I'll refer to is it's a Professional
Organization it was organized in 1965
basically as a networking type
organization so that there was good
communication going on between building
and building and fire officials dating
way back we've
our organization is made up of code
officials both firearm building zoning
officials planners contractors licensed
design professionals so we are not you
know segregated to just code officials
we we want anybody in the construction
industry to be part of our organization
so that we can have good communication
when the organization again when it
originally started it was kind of a
networking group but we've evolved over
that now and what we do is we provide
monthly training to our members in the
so in New Hampshire uh every second two
second Wednesday of the month and those
can be anywhere from three hours just as
much as six hours depending upon the
training that we're offering so in our
in our training is is focused on code
code updates uh state state statute
um any updates to State Statute and any
product
um uh updates that are happening out
there in the field that we feel code
officials should really be focusing on
we also are very involved in the code
development and adoption process we work
very closely with the building code
review board uh the State Fire Marshal's
Office our Home Builders Association the
state associated general contractors and
other stakeholders to work through the
whole code review and code adoption
process so that we're trying to bring in
what really works for New Hampshire even
if there's amendments involved and
to make sure that we are keeping our
currents up to date as much as possible
and the the association is very involved
in the state legislation process for any
legislation that's proposed it will
affect the building of Life Safety codes
in New Hampshire
so when we use the term codes I always
like to say everybody likes to put them
all into one container and the building
you know the codes in New Hampshire are
really when you look at that container
it's several buckets and people forget
that right so as we open up the
container and look inside you've got the
building and building systems codes
which also involves Plumbing electrical
mechanical
um you have Fire and Life Safety housing
regulations and standards Health codes
are enrolled into that and then land use
and zoning regulations if we take that
we group it all into one and then I
think it kind of gets kind of convoluted
when we're trying to look at affordable
housing issue as to what code is really
affecting housing and affordable housing
in New Hampshire
um
so when you look at a code official the
title code official there's actually
many titles that also roll into that
there's the building official
themselves they are typically the leader
of the department they set policy set
budget there's a plans examiner that's
involved in in the process and that is
the person that is involved with
um plan and document review acceptance
and and verification for Code Compliance
permit technicians permit technicians I
always like to refer to as the
ambassadors to our the to our
departments and they are the people that
the public deals with first they answer
the phone they're there to answer emails
they intake permits and in many cases
they are the ones that actually final
accept payment and actually issue
permits
you have inspectors and the inspectors
out there there's a varied you and their
responsible responsible for the
compliance and investigations and
anything basically that is code
regulatory but you have building
electrical mechanical and plumbing
inspectors you have fire inspectors uh
code enforcement housing inspectors and
again Health officers
well most people don't realize all of
these roles it takes all of these roles
to be filled in order for a department
to operate and function you know
successfully
and in many of our communities many many
of our communities
these rules are all filled by one person
so only will you find in the larger
communities or the cities that there'll
be individuals to fill each of these
positions so when you look into your
smaller communities and when people talk
about in times it takes to get permits
permit review and all of this it it does
take some time in the smaller
communities because it's one person
that's doing multiple jobs
so building inspectors what do they
really do right they're out there in the
field looking at you know how is a
building built how is it constructed how
is it safe right so they start off with
Foundation inspections then we get into
what we call rough inspections which is
the building frame the electrical the
plumbing we also get into part of the
frame is the first steps in the fire
safety which is draft stopping and
insulation
and then we get into final inspections
again building building inspections
electrical Mechanical plumbing all those
everything that you see once all the
walls are up and everything they do get
a final inspection to make sure that
it's compliant with code
fire inspectors right they're
responsible for all the Fire and Life
safety compliance inspections of all
non-residential buildings they also get
involved in the place of assembly
inspections and permitting process for
those places of assembly regular school
daycare and Foster Care inspections and
they are involved in Fire and Life
safety compliance inspections of
non-residential and multi-family
residentials when they receive
complaints that they need to follow up
on
our code enforcement and housing
inspectors
they're involved with the code Code
Compliance inspections of of all rental
properties typically occasionally
they'll get into some maintenance codes
that involve single family but mostly
they look into the housing standards
that people rent
enforcement of how they're involved with
the enforcement of housing regulations
and standards that are both locally
adopted and at the state level their
enforcement of property and maintenance
codes if the community has so adopted if
you recall in the state of New Hampshire
it does not adopt a Statewide property
maintenance code that is left specific
specifically in the law to the local
communities
and then we have the enforcement of
local land use regulations that code
enforcements are also tasked with and
then we have our Health Inspectors who
they're involved in the compliance
inspections of commercial food
establishments and those could be at a
specific time or as needed if there's a
complaint licensing of all food
establishments and that could be in many
communities conducted by the state or in
your larger communities that have a
health department they'll conduct those
Food Service licensing
and then compliance inspections of
residential rental buildings and again
specific times that they may do that
they may do a regular inspection of
rental properties or they may need to go
into those properties on an unannounced
basis for an investigation and then they
also are responsible for the enforcement
of all state and local health and
environmental regulations that that can
include Sometimes some of your storm
water erosion Control ordinances
so affordable housing
many people ask you know does do the
building codes allow for affordable
housing and the simple answer that is
yes the building codes
allow for affordable housing because
they allow for minimal standards that
can be there so when a permit is needed
it's any time you're doing you're
constructing a structure that's 200
square foot or larger or is intended for
for human occupancy
so you can build smaller than 200 square
feet in fact some of us has done the
exercise and determined that somewhere
around 170 square feet is adequate in
order to provide housing that meets the
code and and provides the three key
elements and that is means to cook
cleanse and sleep
you can do that 170 square feet
so tiny homes which are permitted by the
building for right now because the state
of New Hampshire through recommendation
of the building code review board has
adopted appendix Q and A tiny home is
anything that is 400 square foot or less
and is not on Wheels by the building
code once we get into Wheels it's a
whole different world the building code
requires a tiny home or any home to be
anchored to a foundation
the building code also allows structures
to be built as close as three feet to
the property lines this is something
that catches people by surprise because
they're so used to 15 foot 30 foot 45
foot setbacks the building code is not
working that way they work on a three
foot setback but there's specific
requirements as far as you may have to
fire rate the side of the building you
may have to limit Windows on that side
of the building just so that we don't
get fire spreading building to building
and then there's varied construction
methods and materials that can be used
out there now and I think it really is
up to the the Builder or the developer
to determine what's most economically
feasible for them to construct the homes
your barriers I truly think come into
when we start looking into land use law
and when we start looking at property
line setbacks lot sizes density
architectural design standards and often
in many of our communities very outdated
ordinances you know you'll look in some
of our communities the the ordinance may
have developed in the 1960s or 70s and
nobody's really brushed that brushed
them over and and cleaned them up so
that they they address current issues
um
so from our Viewpoint from the nhboa how
can legislators help right we think it's
important that the legislature is
cognizant of the important roles that
codes
play in New Hampshire as far as making
the homes and places we work safe for
everyone
that we support the updated codes that
recognizes advances in the product
Industries and the changing needs for
New Hampshire
if the codes don't specifically do
what we need there is an amendment
process that we can work through with
the building code review board and it
works very well
this is a key one for me is that there's
legislators please follow the
established processes for code adoption
codes shouldn't be through legislation
they should be through the processes of
the building code review board if the
codes aren't working correctly for us we
should look at the amendment process
through the building code review board
often we find that we try to amend
building and fire codes through
legislation and that may work great for
the first few years but codes change so
much and needs change so much and it's
very difficult to get that out of
legislation once it's in there and that
becomes a hindrance to us
and then work with established
organizations to address concerns and
what we deem as barriers is the building
code review board New Hampshire building
officials Association the New Hampshire
Fire Marshal's Office Hampshire planners
Association Department of Health and
Human Services and New Hampshire Des we
all work very closely together we
communicate with each other and when we
when any one of us finds that there's an
area that's of concern to our
legislators we we like to address it and
we do communicate
so with that I will yield and take any
questions that you'd like and I'll do my
best to answer them
well thank you Mr McKinney that's been
helpful um I'm gonna open it up
um representative Reed go ahead
thank you so much for your presentation
um so this was a question I had earlier
and was told to wait for the expert and
that's you
um
um so
we had had a presentation a few weeks
ago that talked about how a lot of our
ordinances I mean originally the idea in
the Supreme Court ruled that this was
these ordinances were allowed because of
the basic health safety and Welfare and
how that has suffered from Mission creep
over the many decades and in many cases
some of these ordinances are more
arbitrary or more just kind of what
people would like to see rather than
basically protecting health safety and
Welfare and so one of these applications
we were talking about before you showed
up was a lot minimum requirements and
how can we
tie back to health safety and Welfare
and we started to get into a
conversation about well you know
basically it really is going to come
down to to water and septic for a lot of
these areas and then of course that'll
depend on the the soil type and whatever
and how we can connect that and
basically
what what do you think of that is
essentially the question so like do you
have a sense of for certain soil types A
Certain minimum size would be required
for septic because we have communities
that have 20 acre lot minimums in New
Hampshire and I don't think any of us
can be convinced that you need 20 acres
for a septic personally I think soil
based zoning is is outdated and and
really needs to be looked seriously at
and I believe if you
look at some court cases that may be out
there it's been following the soil based
zoning is is overly restrictive and
that's because of the advances that have
been made in in subsurface systems you
know New Hampshire Des can probably
speak much better to that for for me
than a subsurface bill but you can
certainly put in a a much smaller septic
system now that does the same job that
we did in the 1960s
um so I think soil based
zoning is overly restrictive in my view
as a code official and because of
because it does require the larger Lots
that's where you start getting into your
reduced density that's permitted no some
people appreciate the reduced density in
the New Hampshire character but if
you're looking at affordable housing
maybe some some better
planning designs of you know areas for
affordable housing that you could work
that and and increase the density put in
newer dated septid systems and be able
to provide more housing that
people need
and not to to pin you down but can you
just throw a number out there for like a
lot size minimum that would be
reasonable for today's technology
for today's technology a quarter a
quarter acre lot is not unreasonable
representative McConkey
thank you chairman Alexander and
Christopher Kay thank you for being here
you had two items you spoke of that
sparked my interest
when you spoke of
codes and appendix q and tiny homes and
I fully understand wheels are not wheels
and you talked about that with good
building practices the buildings could
be within three feet to a property line
um
question one is that accepted by most
towns and does that does that tell me
then that a six foot separation
on on a property between buildings with
the proper building codes and access for
putting fires out is acceptable
excellent questions representative
McConkey and um yes the the separation
could be reduced to as much as six feet
provided you're you know and in some
cases that may require residential
sprinkler systems to be to be provided
um rated siding you know fire resistive
siding uh limitation of what they call
limitation of openings so windows and
doors couldn't be constructed on the
sides of those buildings but and again
but if you move out to five feet from
property line and provide the 10 foot
now we start to
um allow more openings we don't get into
the fire rated siding and I think so and
a follow-up we had a presentation a
couple weeks back talking about what's
happening in the country and I guess
Seattle is leading in a couple other
states are talking about permitting
single stair buildings
are you familiar whether we have started
that conversation in our state
would that be for multi-family uh no we
have not started that conversation in
our state and I don't know
the codes are updated nationally every
three years
um and I don't know if that's in the
code for the 2024 or 2027 editions
um
but it's you know if if it comes to the
code and again if it's something that
the legislature would really like to see
a proposal to the building code review
board starts that conversation and they
can amend the current code that we're
under to address that
and if I could if the legislature
thought you know that this was a good
idea and they were asking in your I
understood that you told me it'd be nice
to go through your process as post-dos
legislating
can can can a request be made for a
single item like that as opposed to if
the if the legislature were asked they
thought this was a great idea that we
wouldn't have to take every all the
other baggage that comes with that would
you consider a single item or would the
code state code accept just a single
item in your review the building code
review review board would review any
Amendment that's proposed to them and
determine whether it's compliant and and
provides the you know the level of Life
Safety uh the difficulty is you know
obviously we want to maintain that level
of Life Safety that the codes offer
originally and again if you're getting
into single single stairwell buildings
you probably are already putting
sprinkler systems in the building
because of the number of occupancies
that do you really need the secondary
means and that's the question and and I
know it's being asked around the country
quite a bit so but it's absolutely the
building code review board accepts and
reviews uh single Amendment proposals
all the time I appreciate your time sir
thank you Mr representative Gibbs
thank you
um just uh to be sure I I understood
um and I have it clear
um
for a modern septic system a single acre
lot I'm sorry a quarter acre lot would
be reasonable
I would have to look at that
specifically as far as and I may have
misspoke as far as the quarter raker um
the lot size would still have to be
determined you know through Des process
and Des subsurface
um if there's Municipal Water and
they're doing septic a lot can be
reduced but if they have a well and
septic now that lot size starts to
increase again because you have to have
the radius around the well the
protective radius around the wellness
such so a quarter acre lot for all homes
with septics I would say probably
unreasonable
um and
because most of those would end up being
on private Wells also
so between a quarter acre and what would
be the larger
size that would seem reasonable and I'm
not I'm not asking you for something
that you know you're going to put up
your hand and swear to I understand you
can't do that just an estimate typically
you're you're probably looking into the
three-quarter to one acre lot for
anything to include a septic system and
a private well
so between a quarter acre just for a
septic system and
an acre if it was a septic system and an
individual well
yes I I want to be cautious that again a
lot plays into that if there's Wetlands
on the property
um there's setbacks from Wetlands so
could you get all the way down to a
quarter of acre a lot for a septic
system possibly I'd have to see what the
designs are and what technology allows
now
um but again there's there's often other
issues there ledge that doesn't permit
for it uh again Wetlands that doesn't
permit for it uh well radiuses that
doesn't permit for it so and each of
those that you add in just starts to
increase
the square footage that you'll need
regardless of the system going in
but would anything larger than one acre
be presumptively unreasonable
with the systems that are available out
there I I would say yes I mean one acre
lots would be probably the the minimum
you'd the one you'd want to go
and be safe but I
again I'm not asking you to put your
hand up and swear to it and again I I
gotta defer a lot to subsurface systems
to Des
they are much more knowledgeable on them
than I am
a lot of these are good questions I'll
be reaching out to Des lots of good
questions for that okay yeah thank you
super
it's all good representative
thank you thank you for uh taking the
questions you said that soil based
zoning is Antiquated
um what what type of zoning do you think
is not Antiquated is you know
what what if you're trying to base
something on some facts on the ground
and say like this is what you need to
consider to consider to say the the size
of the lot that will be required what
other than zoning would you take in or
uh what other than local soil
like the soil on that property would you
be considering I think those lots really
need to be determined upon you know the
type of subsurface system that you'd be
putting in there your oil radius
requirements um you know again setbacks
again we want to be we have minimum
setbacks in the code
um
but to strictly look at a soil-based
zoning and saying because you know I
have this type of soil it's a minimum
two acre lot or a five acre lot when
there are there are other options that
are out there now you know when those
are windows zoning regulations came in
it was pretty much only one septic
design one or two septic Design Systems
are that were acceptable
there have been plenty there's been
advances in that field so I think that
that allows for some reduced lot sizes
you know in the more rural areas
thank you for for uh that have you
um in your experience with Des have have
they kind of
um
do you think that they're up to date
about
um
being responsive to the technology
versus the soil type and saying like or
are they much more uh rigid as far as
like
um basing everything on like the worst
type of of uh
you know historically built type of
system and saying this is worst case
scenario or they or you know are they
taking into account like hey you might
have this new new process that doesn't
take up as much room and so we're going
to allow that type of um
a system with a smaller radius or what
what have you
I can't speak specifically for Des
um but I who would be the barrier yeah
excuse me who would be the barrier if
not them
who would be the the barrier yeah to say
that hey this is not allowed even though
it's a new
type of system
Des would be the department that would
look at whatever system is proposed but
I've you know in the Years doing this I
found them pretty reasonable to
recognizing newer Technologies
um represent McConkey then
representative thank you uh thank you Mr
chairman of just to my my field is
septic and design and all that sort of
thing I've been added 30 years
um the Department of Environmental
Services subsurface
is the most reasonable part of that
group to work with
there there's a there is a division that
uh that is uh Innovative technology
companies are always uh providing
information to show how their product
works and during the subdivision process
you go through those those soils and
well calculation so I I think it would
be fabulous to bring in someone like a
Don Bucher from the Department who's
high up in that who deals with this
every day of the week we can answer a
lot of your questions a quarter acre lot
that is grandfathered prior to
subdivision is by right allowed to have
a two-bedroom septic eye that helps
answer your question that doesn't mean
every Puerto Rico lot is that good but
you have a grandfathered right so thank
you representative um I have a question
before representative
um
my question I actually have two of them
so can you talk a little bit about
leniency in the code like is there any
what does it look like can you get sorry
the the the what code representative
leniency in the code is there any
um maybe can you give me an anecdote
about it um when you've used it
um number one and I'll hold my other
question
there is room you know the codes are
very well designed and there is room for
a code official to make the time you
know decisions based upon
um technical information they can back
it up you you can use products that
aren't specifically cited in the code
and is a section that addresses that
quite well
um and it's in an area it's called
alternative methods and materials that
is in the code
um I I find in
a lot of code officials don't like to go
that area because of the concern of
liability
um but it's in the code and as long as
you can back it up with um some some
data or testing information why you made
that why you made the decision that you
did
um I think everyone is fine with that so
would you would you say that there's a
concern
there may or may not be more leniency if
the liability
is this word
the way Society is now everybody gets
more concerned with liability than we
did a few years ago so it's just a
matter of making sure that you can back
up your decisions much better than you
did in past
um as far as leniency in the code
there's that type of leniency but there
is also a section in the code that says
no code official has the ability to
waive specific requirements of the code
we have to be careful of that that we're
not waiving the requirement we're
determining that this requirement is
just as good as what the code requires
and this is why and we do have the
ability to do that okay and my second
question is um you seem to
say during your presentation that there
are times when these building ordinances
and codes haven't been looked at for
years and years and years and that
they're you know they come up every so
often
how would you feel about some language
saying that a municipality needs like
should revisit their code every certain
amount of years to
I how often it how often do you find an
Antiquated code that somebody would use
for a reason to deny
a development I think more time in that
that's only that's over into a local
community's uh you know land use and
zoning regulations that you know and you
know having been on a planning before
and shared a planning board before and
going through an updating zoning
regulations it's a very time consuming
process and because some of these
regulations have been around for decades
in some of these communities it often re
means that they're into hiring you know
professional Consultants to do that
which is an expense to the community as
well and it's why it may often not be
done because to do it at a at a
volunteer level it can be you know
pretty involved and very time consuming
for the volunteers to do uh
but you know as far as the building and
fire codes the building of fire codes
are you know again a new code Edition
comes out every three years our building
code review looks at it and either
recommends to move forward with an
updated building of fire code or or or
amend that voting and fire code and move
it forward so
where we really sit
when we may be outdated is is local land
use and zoning regulations
thank you and I think my question was
probably getting towards the same point
of the cheers question but I think I
might be thinking of it from a different
angle am I incorrect in my understanding
that
the the barrier is the municipality so
whilst so let me just give an example
let's say municipality has said in this
area because of the technology that
existed whenever they put this forward
uh the lot minimum is five acres and
that's what the septic systems needed or
maybe they didn't quite need five acres
but that's what they set forth so now
you have somebody who has five acres and
they replace their septic system with
the new technology
and they go to the town and go can I
further develop now because I have this
technology and the town's going to say
likely no in my am I correct that that
is really the barrier in this and not so
much the underlying code
I I believe so yeah yes is that because
because they have minimum lot size
regulations it may or may not be
outdated and again it could be preferred
by the community but you know we I think
we can prove that you can have reduced
lot sizes through improved technologies
that are available
whether it's a subsurface barrels
whether it's the the construction
materials
that you can reduce some of those lot
sizes it's probably not something a lot
of people in the state want to hear you
know we we like the rural character of
New Hampshire
um but you know I I think it's important
to really look into as we said when we
put everything into the codes what
really is preventing
um
more use of land
okay representative Kellen
thank you uh
I would so when you were talking about
these um building uh a safe home as
small as 170 square feet that complies
with the code
um are these like exercises that your
group did or is it a published like
study using this type of
um like these type of methods that you
can achieve this type of of because I
think that might be
um a valuable resource to someone that's
trying to build affordably that say
these are the methods maybe to to use to
be able to get to this home being safe
and you know utilize like are you using
you know a bathroom and uh you know how
are you constructing that to make that
work
um you know solving that for some people
so that they don't have to do um do the
work again
um that would be interesting if that was
published I don't know if you if you
know
um if it is and then also kind of like
what the cost of that building was if if
you could build a 200 square foot home
that houses someone
um you know in addition to kind of the
layout what is the cost of that
structure of the building materials of
that structure so that I think the the
that the public and the committee would
want to know like what is the POS like
the cheapest homes that could be safely
built and so that we have a range of of
of understanding about like what if if
we're trying to reach affordable what is
the best case scenario Target for us it
is a hundred thousand dollar home
possible
in this you know if you know best case
scenario
um or are we shooting for 250 000 as a
as a best case scenario I think that
would be helpful you know for the public
and this committee
do you have any comments on all
Excellence questions thank you and
hopefully I address all of them uh no
the the quick study that we did with the
building officials Association come to
170 square feet was just done between a
few building officials of saying hey
what is the code allow and so that takes
into account that you know there's
specific clearance requirements for any
of your uh bathroom fixtures you know
the water closets the vanities the
showers they have to has to be
clearances around those so when you
calculate in those clearances you you
end up in the area that okay this is the
size that a bathroom would have to be
then we get into can we provide the
kitchen how big how big do you really
need for a kitchen you know right you
have to you have to you know allow for
your appliances do you need a dishwasher
no I don't need a dishwasher I don't
have to have a dishwasher right so you
start to take all of that out and you
get down to the very bare minimum of
what what you need in order to construct
that now is that going to house a family
of three no no it's absolutely not
you're looking at one of true people at
that size and then as your needs
increase the size of the building will
need to increase but even still when you
look at if you can get down to that 200
square foot 170 square foot
um uh building it comes down to your
land use costs
your development costs you know is is
where you're planning to put this
building is there a ledge that you have
to deal with trying to get a foundation
in it are you going to put it put a full
Foundation under it or are you going to
do a slab type Foundation which again
that reduces cost because we don't have
to go down the full fourth the full uh
eight feet to get a a basement in right
um and so there's all of that
development cost and then you also have
to figure in if you have
five acre zoning
will a lender lend on a 200 square foot
home on a five acre lot probably not
because the numbers don't work very well
as far as the value of the home to the
property value
go ahead I think I caught them
thank you I was more I was more focused
on the actual uh the cost of the actual
sticks in the building not not so much
the other intangible or the other
tangible things including you know the
specific State site costs and all of
that stuff
um just the actual building
um I'm also wondering
um
um we talked about or
at a at a conference that I went to
about housing they talked about off-site
building of
um wall structures
um or entire buildings maybe 3D printed
off-site and then shipped in
um not not the traditional modular homes
but how does how does our current code
handling that like say a completely
built uh
well structure that's just assembled on
property here they seem to have some
concerns about the building officials
wanting to kind of do a rough-in
inspection on on a wall that's already
you know has has uh has sheetrock on it
essentially right when it when it
arrives how is that handled if at all
um in in New Hampshire
the code is allowed for it's it's again
in most of those cases there's oversight
with those
producers so somebody is looking at and
doing quality control it may not just be
the building official
so
um
having just completed you know or
actually in the process of a large
building in Nashua that is off-site
constructed and brought in and the walls
erected on site
I actually prefer that type of
construction it's
um very accurate and um so you don't you
don't have the problems with over
nailing or under nailing
um bad cuts that well
it'll work good it's good enough
um so when you do off-site construction
and rely on the technology for it now
the product that you receive on site is
pretty impressive
okay I'm going to try to wrap this up so
I'm going to represent my contact
represent Gibbs and then wrap it up
after that yep thank you Mr chairman
three quick questions
um overall code how many units apartment
units before you have to go to fire
suppression is it three or four units
three units or more okay and if
if those apart I'm from the rural okay
so Fire Chiefs love to throw in a
cistern and depending on how large I
don't know if that's the right term
buried tank and excess for water
if in your opinion or by code if someone
is already using fire suppression in
their units
should that negate the need of then
having to bring in cisterns on top of
that
I have some fire chiefs that are
really like that
my understanding of the fire code is
that a water
protection has to be provided and it's
up to the local Authority having
jurisdiction to determine what that
would be and if you recall several years
ago the state actually put into statute
that you know you can't mandate
sprinkler systems in one and two family
but that is an alternative that's
available to you in the cases and I have
dealt with developments where because of
ledge it would have been very difficult
to put cisterns and extremely expensive
to put systems in so the developer said
will you accept putting sprinklers in in
every home on the development and that
was accepted by the fire chief in that
community so there are options fire
protection has to be provided in some
form a pond uh you know underground
tanks cisterns
um fire sprinkler systems if if and
again I think that comes really down to
the developer to decide what makes the
best economic sense to them to provide
the fire protection that's required by
the fire code
thank you representative Gibbs thank you
um you mentioned
um essentially individual cities and
towns having their own building codes
but also that there are codes produced
by national organizations and updated
regularly and this is true in many areas
um uh for instance the Uniform
Commercial Code we were among the
Commerce Committee and we were working
on adopting some recent changes to the
Uniform Commercial Code and adopting
them on a state basis and once they're
adopted on the state basis they apply
throughout the state that is each
individual city or town doesn't have its
own Commercial Code applicable to the
stores located in that city
um similarly there are design standards
um they're called ANSI standards
American National standards Institute
for accessible housing that kind of
thing that was something that that I was
professionally involved in
um uh and so my question is would it be
possible
um for the legislature to adopt uh a
version of the building code that
came from a National Organization
um and
include a provision for updating or
amending it as necessary and have that
apply uh on a Statewide basis with some
uh variability for local conditions
um so that each individual Town didn't
um
didn't have the
option to set up arbitrary requirements
as far as the State Building Code and
state fire code those are now currently
adopted under state law state statute
RSA 155 a is the state building code and
forgive me I forget the fire code is
adopted through RSA 155a as well
and those are reviewed
um
currently now reviewed every three years
as the codes are update updated
nationally we have a a bit of a
there's language in the RSA that says we
cannot adopt a code that hasn't been at
least in print for a minimum of three
years so currently we're under the 2018
codes the latest edition code is out
right now as the 2024s we'll be looking
to move New Hampshire to the 2021s I
believe within the next two years
so in how that statute is written is
that it's a Statewide code and it
applies to all communities in the state
but there is also a provision in there
for each individual communities to
provide more stringent provisions of the
codes to address local needs so so
it's it's great that we have a Statewide
code
um
but you know the more astringent
Provisions to address local needs
sometimes causes some some heartburn
around the state and the other issue we
really have in the state is right we
have
234 communities only about half of those
communities have adopted what they say a
a code enforcement mechanism so and of
those half half of those communities
probably less than half actually have
full-time you know fully fully staffed
offices for the build enforcement of our
administration of the building code so
the interesting thing is we say we have
a Statewide code and everybody has to
build to the code
but not every Community needs to have a
code official to enforce it
so the statute also says that the
responsibility to build to the code
relies upon the permit holder or the
contractor but what we hear also is that
sometimes there are local officials who
and I don't want to I don't want to be
too specific and I don't want to
make invidious remarks here
um but who seem to almost make it up as
they go along
um and make specific requirements each
time that are not necessarily
evidence-based
um and again back to the Uniform
Commercial Code
um it doesn't happen
um the local the local
officials uh do not get to make specific
commercial requirements on the local
businesses and what I'm wondering and
I'm I'm not saying this would be easy
and I'm not saying I'm asking you to
give a definitive answer but has anyone
ever considered the possibility of doing
something similar with the building code
again allowing selling flexibility for
local needs but making it so that at
least it's not possible
um
to have individualized arbitrary
requirements
yes and that was the intent when New
Hampshire moved to a Statewide building
code you know we've we've had a
Statewide Fire code for decades you know
um
long before we had a Statewide building
code and the intent of the Statewide
building code was to clear that up so
that everybody was working under one
code no matter where you are in the
state and and I think we're we're
getting back there if you remember for a
while in the state we we skipped a few
code process and we went three code
cycles that we didn't we didn't update
our codes and it really came down to we
were kind of it was almost a force type
situation that we were looking at the
inability to receive federal funding
Federal grant monies we had insurance
rate that rates that might be impacted
because of being in a code that was so
update the legislature was great with
working with us we were able to get the
2015 codes adopted and last year
actually in 2022 yes we were able to get
the uh um 2018 codes move forward so
those are in effect those are the 2018
International codes and the 2018 NFL PA
fire codes so those are in effect
and again we are hoping to move those
ahead again to get caught back up from
when we had that long duration of not
adopting current codes we need to we
need to move in a
every other year process for a few years
and then we'll be up to date and then
we'll if we can stay every three years
we'll be in good shape thank you but and
then education right okay well thank you
Bill so much for coming and presenting
to us and I'm sure if we have questions
I can we have the email so we can just
check that out please contact me with
anything thank you so much appreciate it
thank you representative Alexander and
the committee
can you send us the um the slideshow the
that we didn't get to see the slides
or not to me also
of course
all right so our next presentation is
from Newmarket Town planner bark but
dunno Bart thanks for coming
at the invitation of Representative Reed
and representative Delorenzo
thank you
good afternoon uh representative
Alexander and committee my name is
Barbara McDonough I'm the planning
director of the Town New Market
and I'm here specifically to talk about
accessory dwell units
um
and I guess housing in general um I
would say I think
first off accessory dwellings is a tool
in our toolbox that we can use to help
solve the housing crisis that I think
this is experiencing right now
um
and
this you know it's very
it's a very useful tool I believe I
think it'd be powerful it's less
impactful into our communities the
environment also
potentially costs I think one thing
right now that is
a barrier to any Housing Development
right now is cost financing really
difficult in this climate but I think
our overall goal if we extend our time
Horizon on the housing is to set the
state up in a manner that allows for it
to build when prices do come down
so that's why I think amending the
accessory dwelling unit
um statue and also potentially looking
at other statutes
that allow for more density would be
prudent and continue
um you know reviewing that what makes
sense another critical aspect is
infrastructure
it's really critical
um especially I know the last
presentation we talked about septids
receiving early septic system that
septic has to go somewhere you need to
go to a wastewater treatment facility
so in our rural communities it might be
imperative not every Community can build
one they're very expensive but
maintaining them and upgrading them
strategically so that sections that is
taken from communities can be placed
there
in a very environmentally
um a sustainable way so
um like I said keep this really brief
and I'll happy to answer anything about
municipalities what we're experiencing
new market and maybe some ideas moving
forward if you have anything on zoning
orange changes but
um
upgrade infrastructure allow for more
flexibility for um from the state
statutes to allow for different types of
housing
and allow for more density where
appropriate so that's my three things I
want to communicate to you all and I'll
happy to answer any questions you have
from municipality level
uh represent McConkey
we just amended our ordinance to allow
for it by right
nope uh so the oh
sure so
New Market I believe had
accessory dwelling they used to call
them accessory Apartments
since 1996.
um it was by special exception so you
had to go to the Zone board adjustment
for um that approval and if anyone knows
for conditional use or in Newmarket we
call a special use permit and really you
just have to demonstrate like six
criteria I mean it was approved but it
was still a barrier
um at that time it only allowed for a
touch
and you had to obtain a variance
before going to the you know the same
body to ask for the special exception
and they're always denied and it
Newmarket being a very old Community has
a lot of non-conformities and
um and the applications made sense but
the purpose of the zoning was contrary
to it and they were very stringent
um so there was no flexibility there at
all so
and um also New Market between 1996 and
present day only Built 40 adus
so why why is that that doesn't seem
like a lot uh yeah I think it was a lot
of hurdles
um it also part of the
um
are the criteria one of the Criterium
was that all aspects of the law had to
be conforming
so New Market being 17 I don't know 40
something 50 something had a lot of
non-conformities and zonings evolved
Through The Years where there was a
period where there was a pendulum swing
to anti-development
so
um because of that you didn't see it
after
and that was one of the things we
addressed in the new ordinance I can go
into in a little more detail on the
ordinance Amendment
so uh what we did in New Market recently
so what really spurred this was Town
Council and plan board had a meeting to
you know see where they can address
um
issues or roadblocks impediments to
Housing Development and one of them was
adus they thought it was a good
opportunity a good start
to you know start the conversation and
see if there's you know some consensus
there so
um Town Council directed plan board and
kind of side note here uh planning board
and new markets elected so so actually
two different you know elected bodies
which is a interesting for a town that
size
um and
So the plan board um started reviewing
it and looking over and seeing where
there was some
um some flexibility in places to improve
and they did that and one of them was
that if you're a single family lot
regardless of your Conformity you could
build an Adu by right
either attached
um or detach as well if you had an
existing structure so I'm thinking of
your barn supercarriage you know like
that so but if you're going to build
something new you have to conform at
least to your setbacks but your lot size
didn't matter
so long as you are a single family love
uh conform not legally non-conformisting
of them a lot
so um so that that passed um will ever
detached the minimum size the range was
between 300 and a thousand square feet
um one of the other
caveats there was
um if we're not contrary to the state
law which you have to allow for 750
square feet size
um
he Adu had to be 80 percent of the
square footage of the single family
dwelling this goes to scale you know you
kind of want to make sure the scale of
your accessory dwelling unit doesn't
exceed the scale of your primary
dwelling unit so which is bigger you
know you wanna you want
you want to look at it's like this is an
accessory dwelling unit this is not my
primary dwell unit so that was that was
the concern
um so that was put into it
um there's a bunch of other Provisions
going to if you wish but um but it was
well received we did initially
um
uh the language tried to go for two uh
accessory dual units
um through a special use primary or
conditional use but um the town at that
time felt that wasn't appropriate
um because we really want to see how
this would take off and I'll report that
no permits have been filed
um but that just goes back to my other
point because I don't think anyone can
afford it
okay yeah go ahead
um thank you representative McConkey
representative representative McDonough
I'm apologize Mr McDonough is of course
my town planner and he's been very
instrumental for full disclosure and in
helping with hb423
um but you've been the planner in New
Market for I think two years or so I
started last April so a little over a
year a little over a year
um so since he's comment hasn't been so
controversial but I think I started this
three or three and a half years ago and
it was started by that constituent who
was being denied the ability to put an
in-law apartment inside of his detached
garage and at that time I went to the
then Town planner of Newmarket not Mr
McDonough who and I got into a you know
a philosophical debate about needing
more housing and this is before the
housing crisis was as bad as it is now
and was told oh those people we do
enough for those people they have the
apartment and the trailers and so I'm
very happy we have Mr McDonough now but
the point is is that it was it was a
fight I started in response to that I
started a little group called New Market
Housing Coalition and we flooded a
planning board meeting with people this
is right at the beginning of the
pandemic and we all went on zoom and
insisted on ideas so it was actually a
fight before Mr McDonough got there and
but I'm very very glad we have him now
episode
um I just want to say one more thing and
we do allow for manufacturer homes that
allow uh detached in Newmarket so
there's another thing that we do uh
representative Damon
thank you thank you take my question
can you expand on you said the three
concepts the legislature might work on
on the more flexibility for different
types of housing
yeah I think Numark is about to embark
on this adventure um we're going to
rezone part of the town and part of the
idea is at missing middle housing you
might have heard that term before so I
think about your duplexes just
fourplexes six plexus
in Newmarket we have a lot of
single-family homes and we have
a lot of apartment buildings eight plus
units we have nothing in the middle
and that's where I think we can make a
large Headway um large advances
um and what you're doing there too is
you're not transforming your
neighborhoods you're integrating into
your neighborhoods
my hypothesis is people understand
there's a housing issue there's a
housing crisis in the country especially
in New England and New Hampshire
the problem is their major asset is
their property in their house and they
don't want that to be affected
so the challenge is how do you integrate
more density
without the perception of people's
properties being
negatively affected or impacted if
that's right or wrong you know the
Market's very subjective as we know so
but I think you can do it in a very
mindful way
so what we're doing is focusing in New
Market what we're doing is focuses on
missing middle housing and we're going
to go from a form-based code method
and it's going to be a community
iterative process as we go through the
zoning amendment process so you know
doing small focus groups in
neighborhoods you know this is which
we're doing New Market I'm not sure you
know every Community is going to be
different but
creating consensus on design I think
design is really important when you're
asking for more density in neighborhoods
so because people just
in general I think in human nature
change is
um
it's not it's hard to accept but it's
inevitable so
um so it's really bringing everyone to
the table brings stakeholders to the
table and you know creating consensus
you know consensus you know no one's
happy but they're happy to move forward
with what they do so
um but I think that's that's that's my
hypothesis that's what we want to go
with and that could change too but if
the legislator were to look into missing
middle housing like those you know those
medium densely small density options I
think that could go a long way
so that like for example the four Plex
um you know legislation you know that
could be fine-tuned and tailored and you
know
um I think there might be some
opportunity there for the legislative
look up
great representative
thank you
um do you go do you guys have
um septic in sewer
um over a large part of your or how much
percentage I guess of your of your um
town and also when you are have these
zoning uh changes what percentage do you
believe is non-conforming because of
that because under the existing
um regulations and art is part of your
goal to reduce
the the amount of non-conformity by the
um between the zoning ordinance and what
is the situation on the ground yeah um
New Market is a lot of non-conforming
they're legally non-conforming
structures
um but
um and lots so the goal of zoning is
always to try to you know find that
balance you know you know bring
everything into conformance
um
and you know realistically you can't do
that
um and that process takes a long time so
you kind of identify areas
um that you think is the
the easiest I guess lack of a better
word to try to fix
um so so in that in that area you know
we we try to focus on you know where are
those opportunities we can Max we can
leverage most to bring things in more
um Conformity and also self an issue a
problem that the town has
um the circle back to your septic and
Wastewater
um at the core downtown
and the surrounding the downtown is all
on Water and Sewer As you move further
away from that that's when you
um
go into septic systems and Wells
so percentage
it's hard to say I would say
rough you know Russ estimate I would say
70 septic well 30 sewer
um so that's where you see all your core
density too because of that
um
and
you know new markets in a really good
position right now they made a lot of
investment in their wastewater treatment
facility and their Wells and
um you know we have a the capacity to
expand
um that's why we're looking at certain
areas in town where we can we're for
instance on Route 108 going towards the
Durham line
um we laid um septic and water there in
anticipation that something will be done
in the future so when they're redoing
108 or renovating it we had that
opportunity so I think
where you want to con um
concentrate your density is where you
have your infrastructure
and you know for the adus when we made
these changes these aren't really large
asks on the property you know every
property is going to be different so
this is where you want to see that type
of development you don't want to see
your large developments and your rural
area you want to see your density
downtown or where the infrastructure is
where it's located and you want to
preserve those areas too
so I think as communities look to add
density
um maybe it's specifically in those core
areas of you know more urban areas of
communities
okay
thank you
um as you built out this infrastructure
for your water and sewer did were you
um also updating the density for those
that area so that
um that more people will be able to tie
in and and did you
um
um as far as there's a you know the
fixed cost per mile
um was there a Target when you were
looking at that possible increase of
density as far as like the the burden
for each individual
taxpayer using that that property right
yeah so I think at the time the idea was
two two things one there was an
opportunity from dot when they were
renovating 108. they were ripping
everything up so it said this is a good
opportunity to expand so they did that
in anticipation that's something that
Corridor will um will take place in the
future the second part of that question
is the town engaged with a consultant to
look at gateways in the town so um
towards Epping Durham and then new
fields in anticipation that you know
there will be future development down
there on those in those areas and we
focus on the Durham one the North
Gateway right now as
the first step because that's where the
infrastructure is so answer your
question yes as we look to expand
infrastructure that's where we want to
see development and you know the more
people that are on it the less you know
it's going to be in a way we also look
for Grants so we're not just putting the
whole burden on the user we're also
looking at other opportunities to
supplement
um
um costs or so the reduced cost for
instance um
we have sepsis receiving and we're
upgrading that in order to take on other
communities because
um right now some some of our
communities surrounding Newmarket aren't
able to take it and their wastewater
treatment so New Market has stepped up
and was able to
um take on that so seeing there's such a
demand we had the funding or at least
the mechanisms to upgrade the septage
receiving so in anticipation we you know
take on more so
and that's that saves costs that's money
generated
right there uh representative Conkey
um and thank you you gave me a new term
I didn't know missing middle housing is
that a reference and has your town
starting putting an ordinance together
on that or you're you're about to okay
so we received um invest New Hampshire
hop Grant I received a hundred thousand
dollars 125 000 uh 25 000 is going to
our Master Plan update which will begin
next year
and then the other hundred thousands
going towards the rezoning effort so
that seems like a large sum and it is
um but again the idea is the the
approach we're taking it's going to be
Community
um events so we're going out to you know
doing small focus groups you know um and
um a lot of Tourette's in order to
create consensus and then also design so
hiring an architect you know to
you know as they're having these
conversations sketch up what they're
hearing and then from there we um engage
with a land use expert and they um
design a form-based code so when that
when that draft becomes available if you
could send that to Chairman that would
be absolutely no matter when it's done
and do I understand you right so I I
would I would hear a term used in cities
all the time in Phil I've got a I've got
a vacant lot and you know that's not
being used in a village or whatever but
you're actually talking about adding
instead of infill on a separate lot
you're saying that there might be a
possibility put another structure into
that lot or would it be added on to that
lot yeah onto the existing building so
yeah I think every lot's going to be
different circumstance but there might
be opportunities where
um the large lot is large enough based
on the codes
um requirements are the zoning codes
requirements and you can add a new
structure you know maybe it's smaller
but you can add something that's kind of
what we're trying to accomplish with the
accessory dwelling unit ordinance a new
market when we amended the you know add
smaller footprint
structures thank you uh representative
thank you thank you for taking another
question how um
my in my community we kind of contract
our planner to the regional Planning
Commission
um how much
um
how is your relationship with them I
guess have they been very helpful of as
far as like giving ideas or or
um
yeah just like how do you see that kind
of relationship between
um your town and the regional Planning
Commission
I think it's critical there are a huge
asset to the municipality they help
identify Grant monies they help you know
they're really they're actually you know
essential to transportation
um and um in front of the housing
perspective
um
they're always there to help you figure
out so you know Newmark is different you
know I'm I'm the planner there so
um I use them in a different capacity
than other municipalities um do but
um the communities that I know that of
Stratford Regional Planning Commission
do contract with they're doing a lot for
them so
um so I think they're a huge asset and
I'm very grateful for their support
thank you
um as far since you guys have just
recently kind of expanded your water and
sewer stuff and we're looking for kind
of money to go into that did you use
um
impact fees as far for water do you have
an impact fee for water and sewer and
um was the six-year time frame do you
think that was
um too short for being able to hold on
to water impact fees and if the state
um I guess kind of like how that funding
mechanism went and if the state was
um
trying to support that in some way maybe
um you know through low interest money
or something along those lines what
how would that be received and if there
are strings attached saying that you had
to be you know more density would you do
you think that your community would have
still accepted it if it if they'd said
hey you have to have increased density
if on this along this this line if
you're going to be accepting our you
know
our money would use what would you think
about that yeah so New Market um
and recently has amended it to remove
water and sewer interesting move towards
assistant development charge
so basically what that does is takes all
the assets
Water and Sewer so they're going to be
two different rates and creates a new
um buy-in fee based on
um you know the depreciation
appreciation the investment and whatnot
and puts it all into one you know buy
and fee moving forward so it hasn't been
adopted yet plain board still has to
amend the methodology
um so uh so we're under that process but
yeah the six year you know it's really
it's really Community specific really
um you know based on the community's
needs from water to sewer perspective
um you know if there's a limited
um
uh if there's not a lot of development
and there's
you know limited infrastructure might
not be worth it at all so
um I would say that's a community
specific issue for impact fees but I do
see their usefulness
could there be a maybe new language
introduced to allow for more time
sure
um but you know maybe the legislature
should look at you know what are those
requirements so left for more time you
know to allow those impact fees to stay
with the municipality before the return
to the developer or the landowner
um you know maybe there's a set of
criteria but you have to
fulfill
um I don't know the answer question but
great all right I'm gonna go
representative Delorenzo representative
Gibbs representative Reed and then we're
gonna call it on this thank you Mr here
um good afternoon Mr mcdonner nice to
meet you
um you know what the um changes and um
affordable housing opportunities in the
town of Newmarket for instance instant
CM Adu units and then the um
the missing middle proposed missing
middle housing has been been any
pushback from residents about fears of
some of that
housing becoming student housing
yeah there's always a new market always
had that um that um kind of Specter you
know but we're seeing a new market is
the students are retreating there's a
lot of housing being built in Durham and
surrounding communities
and a really I indicator that as we're
losing busing the Wildcat Transit is no
longer going to be servicing a new
market so ridership is down
um but there's still always that
um that fear it's going to be more
student housing you know more density
means more students I don't necessarily
agree with that
um just based on the amount of housing
that's available today and behavior of
students they're going to be as close as
possible I want to be close as possible
to the university so um you know but
there's always
it's always worth having those
conversations and you know understand
why that still exists then
thank you
representative Gibbs thank you
um you mentioned that uh Newmarket is in
the process of changing from a specific
order and Sewer impact fee to a to
including that in a generalized uh
development fee
um
that is allowable under current statutes
um uh because we were talking earlier
the reason that I asked is because we
were talking earlier about uh current
statutes requiring certain types of fees
to be designated only for specific uses
as for order and Sewer or schools or
fire
um but in fact you're able to commingle
it all in one uh development fee account
right so this is just specific to Water
and Sewer on the system development
charts we'll still have impact fees for
recreation in schools so those will
still be assessed as legislated right
now in New Market so the reason why the
town's moving forward with this approach
is that
there has to be a Nexus between a
development and the impact fee so for
instance expanding a sewer line wire
line to that specific parcel land that
affects the
um
that the development paid for
whereas the system development charge
you can use that for anything within the
system so you know upgrade your you know
sewer treatment plan expanding uh water
line where it needs to be so there's
more flexibility for the municipality
under the system development charge to
utilize that money more effectively to
target areas where your overall system
needs it that's that's the main impetus
so the development fee will in fact
still go towards Water and Sewer uh but
it can be used more broadly to improve
capacity rather than just extending the
lines exactly more targeted I mean
there's more flexibility for for the
municipality to utilize that money to
its best potential thank you
representative
thank you and obviously thank you for
coming today
um so I was hoping since we did bring
you here specifically
um because of your work with Adu in town
and also
um vetting uh hb423 uh if I could just
go through real quick I know you've read
it before but the points in hb423 so
that um we could hear directly any
commentary you might have so I'm just
going to kind of like a greatest hits
highlight situation so HP 423 primarily
it changes the definition of attached
from the and this is something that
Newmarket specifically adopted
um from specifically attached to also
include completely contained within a
pre-existing detached structure and then
says that you have the right to have
your one at least one Adu detached and
then the town may require that the
second Adu have by right be attached by
this new definition
it also
increases the square footage that a town
can restrict down to from 750 to a
thousand for one and 850 for any other
Adu I did hear you say specifically
Newmarket wanted to also say no more
than 80 percent of the
primary residents
um and then another thing that we have
here is
um the re the ability for the
municipality to require one of those two
adus to meet Workforce housing
requirements
um and I had spoken about this earlier
but the idea behind that was twofold not
only to get to affordable housing
obviously but also to kind of prevent
the um the the problem that has been
raised of people building Aid use
specifically for short-term rentals
um and then I did add at the end here
the ability for municipality to require
a lot size of no more than a half acre
for the second Adu and finally the the
last thing this is in the bill but that
has been raised is the idea of
um of addressing the parking
requirements because many I wasn't aware
of this I don't know that this has been
an issue in New Market but here we hear
that many municipalities have had
onerous parking requirements on their
Adu uh the one that exists by right um
as kind of an effective way of denying
adus so those are kind of the highlights
and then a couple extra ideas and I just
wanted to open it up to you for any of
your thoughts on any of those
people it was parking um you know as the
last thing mentioned so I'll speak to
that
um
what Newmarket did was you just had to
demonstrate that you have enough parking
for the primary and accessory dwelling
unit the idea was that there's going to
be a lot of flexibility in different
situations
and different contexts so basically the
build and inspector or building official
go out you know meet with the applicant
and the app can either you know with a
site plan obviously with the building
permit
and to show that Parkinson's sufficient
and once that becomes a problem then you
know a enforcement order will go out
so we don't really require we just say
demonstrate that you have enough because
it could be a five acre lot
and you know so or you have a you know
smaller lot but you have enough parking
so we wanted to be as flexible as
possible without being too olderous but
understand that we want to make sure
parking is provided for so I was
approach that we took
um
just looking at line six
um the first page
I think that needs to be worked on I
think
it might be redundant you might already
say
I would just say just if you want to
keep it clean may it work on that
definition with that new language right
there from line six to line seven or
just strike it out and then just
um speak to it where detached
um units are spoken to
uh I don't know which section that is
but
um
I think it's a little confusing
so if you want to take a look at that
next session
um
um let's see
and then
I like the idea of a thousand square
feet this is line 18 19. to and then the
second one has to be 850. that goes back
to my early come on scale I think that's
really important
um
so I think you um the bill got that
right
um and then
I I do you know
you know be an advocate for Workforce
housing too but understand that every
Community is going to be different
I think right now it's a good first step
with may you know require affordable
housing because I think that
conversation needs to be evolved and
it's got to be slow walk potentially
because there's a lot of different
um
a lot of different interests in this so
I think it's a good first step
moving towards that direction
um you know obviously I would like to
see it more but
um there's got to be some compromise
there as well
um
and
I like the May and the interior door
part I think that's the shallow is too
onerous on line 26 sorry I'm jumping
around here
um I think that's a good Amendment there
would you believe I had pushback on that
in committee okay I was surprised
because the idea is you're going to have
the primary dwelling like typically in
municipalities and I think the statues
requires us uh a dozen actually but at
least a new market the property owner
has to live on lot
so you've seen that in a lot of
communities so I'm not sure if that's
too much
but that's why you know leading up to
the property owner in that case might be
best
um
so the state telling that it has to be
because I know what are you trying to
achieve I guess no it's fine I just
didn't know if there was any I didn't
understand the pushback I got on May
um instead of shall and I didn't know if
there was like if you had heard any
other rationale of why we would want to
force people to have a door between the
two
you know I wasn't there for that
conversation when the statue was first
adopted so
um
I'm not sure
well thank you very much for your
expertise and coming to the committee
it's been very helpful I'm happy any
follow-up too please contact me any
follow-up questions thank you very much
thank you
yeah we're gonna take a three minute
break and then we're gonna go into our
last presentation
thank you
James yeah
let's do that
question time for a break
ing students yeah
suppose
that's awesome
there are two representative
and then there's
a teacher
um
my question
is
ready
thank you
no I wish I had one I looked him up
online and I watched some of the other
presenters I didn't notice one utilizing
one or I would have
emailed it or if there is a link to it
smoothies
nice oh
see you
guys
yeah oh God does bread mean oh
it's on
there we go
foreign
we're going to get started this special
committee on housing I want to welcome
up
um first
uh Jessica marginson from Granite City
organizing project thanks for coming
thank you very much
I'll turn this to make sure everybody
can hear me properly sure first I wanted
to say thank you
thank you for creating the special
committee that focuses on housing needs
and thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak to you today
I hope we can all agree that housing is
a basic human need
but the part I think that we are all
having trouble with is how to fill this
need
in my capacity as a tenant organizer
with gsop I have helped many individuals
and families by holding a weekly tenant
clinic in Manchester New Hampshire this
is a space created to help New Hampshire
residents find rental assistance utility
assistance learn their rights and apply
for legal assistance this tenant Clinic
started as an eviction Clinic due to the
overwhelming number of renovation
evictions happening across our state
one of the best phrases I heard
unfortunately
in one of our sessions to describe it
was I step outside of my apartment and I
look to my left and there's a for sale
sign and when I look to my right there's
a for sale sign everywhere around me is
for sale
we saw this across multiple price ranges
with apartment buildings and houses
selling either before they hit the
market or just one to three days after
showing we saw that our dilapidated
housing or what investors call C-Class
properties started getting bought up
with the head spending speed
and as the evictions grew in Number the
available affording housing unit started
to become harder and harder to find
the overwhelming amount of good cause
renovation addictions wiped out a large
portion of naturally occurring
affordable housing across our state
coupled with the unprecedented increases
in rent brought to the foreground the
need for affordable housing
those two words affordable housing held
such a stigma in our state for so long
till now
it is a very popular phrase and finally
everybody's utilizing it from those of
us who need it to those building it it's
talked about when variances and
exceptions are asked for as a new Hot
Topic phrase
but those two words are so broad as they
are currently defined what I feel is
needed is a better look and
understanding into the income
classifications from HUD which focuses
on the area median income or the
abbreviation you hear a lot especially
for me Ami and that is where we're going
to start with the paper that I passed
out to everybody
I am a Tena organizer with gsop but I am
also on the Manchester housing
commission
where I try and help fight for more
housing for all and then this we created
this form to better help everyone
um
we'll go into that so I just wanted to
explain that a little bit
what I feel is needed is a better
looking understanding into the income
classifications from HUD which focuses
on the area median income this chart
covers 30 Ami extremely low income all
the way to 100 Ami fair market middle
income to help you better be able to
understand this I have printed up to
Manchester New Hampshire's quick
reference housing guide that was created
by our Housing Commission in an effort
to help our aldermen zoning and planning
board better understand terms use and
how they are applied the first part you
will see labeled in the lower left hand
section of the front page
is
um
30 Ami extremely low income
what we did with this chart is break it
down to show what 30 percent of each
income classification would look like
since HUD qualifies affordable rent
being 30 percent of one's income
what that means is for a single
individual
with the income no higher than 21 000
per year
what that represents is 525 dollars a
month in rent we don't have that
and when you have a family of five that
is still at 30 Ami extremely low income
and their top income is 37 190 a year
for a five-person household what that
means to them is that the only income
qualified for a rent of nine hundred and
thirty dollars a month most boarding
rooms and Studios charge this much if
not more but yet five people in a studio
apartment or a boarding room would
surpass occupancy levels allowed due to
size
I've seen families have to split up one
family I helped ended up with the mother
and two children in Tilton
with family and the father and their
other two children stayed in Manchester
where he held a job
that is not the only family this has
happened to and it's not the furthest
people have had to go to find housing
these two areas need to be highlighted
and uplifted 30 Ami and 50 Ami because
we do not have rents to meet their needs
we just don't have it unless it's under
HUD or housing
supported housing models the private
landlords can't offer rent like that now
and what we can see as we take a look at
this chart is that you do not start
seeing realistic rent amounts until we
get closer to 60 and 80 percent area
median income I try to explain to those
that may not understand that those at 80
and 100 Ami may not always like the
cheaper more affordable apartments but
yet they are still an option for them
whereas those at 30 and 50 percent area
median income have their only uh have
only their options since they cannot
afford more expensive units thus making
their options much more limited and
scarce this leads to a multitude of
other services needing to be utilized to
keep them housed while they wait for an
available unit in their range to become
available
which leads to my last topic the missing
piece
right above this section you will see
the housing terminology section and at
the bottom of the list you'll find
Supportive Housing
this is something greatly needed in
multiple communities across our state as
as it is not easy to just move to a new
affordable apartment
it can take six months to a year to
sometimes find and qualify for these
Supportive Housing Services can be quite
expensive for the municipalities to face
on their own since it requires multiple
services and non-profits to be able to
meet that need currently we need to see
an increased funding to the
municipalities for this goal
and I just want to be able to stop and
answer any questions you may have
especially when you look at this it's
something that I've seen as the greatest
need emerge as I spoke of those at 80
and 100 they have much more options
available the housing projects I'm
seeing coming out if you take a look at
Manchester right now what we have on the
books
you'll see that
1439 units are approved and in progress
the number of those being offered below
fair market 210.
we're not going to meet our current need
without more funding and more help with
this
thank you okay thank you very much um I
have just one quick question before I
open it up
um on the bottom right hand corner of
your sheet the current Manchester rental
pricing I'm seeing that the fair market
rents for Manchester as determined by
Hud is actually
meeting
the median rent it's keeping up
okay as the median rent so I guess I'm
wondering like
yeah that part gets tricky so that added
in for HUD so when we um when someone
has a housing Choice voucher those are
the rents that they're allowed that
fully doesn't represent what rents are
being actually offered in Manchester
commonly you will see 1600 on a two
bedroom and up
um so that's hard
rates right there so if you have a
housing Choice voucher that is the rent
you have to hit what that also does show
is
um
we also show the variances in there but
which one
do you see that it's close
well I was like thinking for a two
bedroom the fair market rent as
determined by Hud is 1646. yeah the
actual median rent is 1582 so it doesn't
seem
to me like
do you see the key part in that missing
the Amis to your left that's how um
that's why I honestly I didn't really
agree with having this part in there
because it doesn't fully represent that
these are HUD prices only I think I'm
going to take that back to the
commission and let them know that we do
need to
label this better because that does get
confusing
I know a lot about housing after sitting
through these meetings and that's why I
was like very confused by that chart so
yeah so um and that's the other hard
part is getting the rent slow enough for
their vouchers to be able to exist there
okay representative Gibbs thank you
um
as I recall
um Hud's income limit classifications
are done by County so uh the income
classifications that you have in the
lower left hand Square rectangle
um are those for Hillsborough County
correct it'd be all are centered around
Manchester
I'm sorry it should be Hillsborough
County because they're all centered on
marriage right right so say if I were
looking at Merrimack or Rockingham
County they would be different yes yes
thank you slightly
representative McConkey
uh chairman and thank you for pulling
this together as the chairman mentioned
we've seen this chart done 20 different
ways I like your approach thank you this
I have to give credit to Katie she's
also on our Housing Commission Marquis
she really she took up quite a few
months to put this together we had many
meetings back and forth thank you thank
you a lot of work
does anyone else have questions
okay thank you very much oh
representative Damon
so I'm newbie
related to
the income classifications which of
those in classifications qualify for
Section 8
or is it you're up to 50 Ami when you're
looking at um for housing Choice
vouchers it's up to 50 Ami
thank you thank you
sorry uh it's considered low income and
very low income
um which uh is as you said 30 percent
and and fifty percent wow um for HUD
actually 80 is considered to be moderate
income uh at least as as they were doing
it
um up until 2016 which was uh when I
retired from mud right you and me both
agree that that's what low income is is
30 and 50 but unfortunately we have this
to go by is what they qualify 80 Ami is
considered low income also and when
you're looking at 80 Ami one person 55
950 they're going to qualify for that
one bedroom apartment long before I will
at my lower thirty percent Ami
um
so
my options are very minimal whereas
somebody at 80 Ami can go all the way
down the board if they must and they can
wait for the other apartments to come
along but those of us at 30 and 50 we
can't wait because we're out on the
streets
um we have nowhere to go there's not
enough places the tenants I help
routinely take six months to a year and
they try hard they're calling every day
we're creating worksheets we're getting
inventive I help tenants put together a
tenant resume to help them stand out we
are trying everything and it just takes
time A real estate agent will tell you
look at hundreds of calls on a low
income a truly low income of 30 or 80
percent you'll get multiple those that
are renting a couple thousand and up
five to twenty
that is the difference in the need
and that is the difference in what is
available out there
and we desperately need something for
thirty percent and fifty percent even if
it's a supportive model such as
um Supportive Housing
creating we saw the hotels were great
then Heap program is over we don't have
that catch anymore so we have to get
busy and create some type of Supportive
Housing need to meet that until they're
able to find something because with
enough hard work they will we get enough
places built they also will but there's
also uplifting helping raise their
income to meet to be able to qualify
finding the resources they need to fill
to be able to qualify getting them on
list and being able to wait somewhere
for your voucher to become available all
these things are important and if we
work together those could be done and
I'd rather put our money into uplifting
others instead of just getting by on the
side with the shelter
thank you thank you Miss Parkinson I
appreciate it any other questions
yes ma'am
representative Delorenzo thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um so when we look at Supportive Housing
does that include transitional housing
yes um a supportive model would have
something that would cover your income
resources mental health needs
um
what is the other one
recovery needs
um
educational needs because sometimes
people are underemployed and with a
little bit of help they can raise their
income levels and be able to qualify and
get in somewhere so bringing that part
back of training
um all sorts of stuff like that
I the mayor has asked me to put my model
together because I have a recycling
model like I want to pull in a bank and
I want to create an escrow account a
savings deposit in a checking account so
while they're at this transitional
housing 30 percent of their income is
going into this escrow account so when
they move out they have their own
security deposit to be able to reuse the
first month's rent all these things
because I know this is hard on our state
to be able to supply and produce
but we can create these supportive
models and help people with them
thank you thank you
okay I want to um invite up Miss A Jane
Haig from Manchester housing Alliance oh
thank you very much
um my name is Jane hake and I work with
a Manchester housing Alliance which is
an informal activist group
I appreciate the opportunity to address
the committee I'm a retired history
Professor now I'm a full-time activist
uh my specialty is research I got
interested in the housing issues when
the homelessness crisis hit Manchester
sometime at the end of 2020 which I just
thought was appalling
and it continues to be appalling so my
self-assigned mission has been to
understand why we're in a housing crisis
how we can get out of it so I've read
every report produced by every Committee
in the state I attend every housing
meeting all the New Hampshire Housing
Finance programs I've watched all this
committee's meetings on YouTube and
attend all the local Planning and Zoning
meetings
um I have been very impressed with the
breadth and depth of experience of the
members of this particular committee
especially the depth of experience and
the breadth and the various aspects of
the housing market and the Housing
Industry I have to tell you there's some
naysayers that are out there that are
going like I don't know what they can do
but I keep telling them that I think
that developing a consensus about ways
to tackle the housing problem here in
New Hampshire is extremely important
so I recently heard from a friend who
saw a development going up near her home
in Auburn
this development was a 55 and older
single-family home kind of a condo
development where the units were selling
for something like six hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
um I was appalled um I think we can all
agree New Hampshire does not need any
more of these developments and that the
people who are buying them are probably
not from New Hampshire
and it may have just sold a house in
Massachusetts and be buying for cash
um yet there's nothing that we can
really do to stop the developer from
building this type of development if
this is what the particular developer
who's bought the land thinks that they
can make the most money building or just
what they feel like building
um they're probably selling the units
for cash
um
and so
as far as I can see there's nothing in
particular that would incentivize the
Builder to build Workforce multi-family
housing for families of workers
and that's exactly why the state has to
concern itself with housing
so as I've listened to your meetings and
contemplated the various issues here are
some major issues first of all zoning
and financing and affordability you've
heard a lot about zoning and I know you
all are focused on zoning and it's
definitely a huge part of the problem
both in the rural areas and in the
smaller towns and to a smaller extent in
the larger communities like Manchester I
can't tell you how excited I was about
the zoning Atlas I know we all sort of
started out these meetings going like I
don't know where is this happening and
fortuitously the atlas has come along at
just the right moment I'm not sure if
it's actually at its final usable state
but I understand that it soon will be
um solving zoning issues alone is not
going to solve the problem that's really
the guts of the issue and I think Mr
McDonough said that they've passed this
Adu new
um
availability in Newmarket and yet
nobody's built in Adu because nobody can
afford to
um I priced one myself or my house
and I think it would be at least 150 or
you know maybe more two hundred thousand
dollars to put in an Adu uh my friend
who's the Adu specialist in Manchester
tells me that most of the adus are sort
of a multi a family thing where there's
a
children and parents and the parents
sell their house they put their money
into the Adu at the Children's House
it's not people going out and building a
rental unit for the General Market at
all
so that's not really
um changing zoning so smaller houses can
be built on smaller Lots is going to
help the housing affordability but it's
not by itself going to solve the problem
unless median income buyers can get
financing from local banks
and to check this proposition
I Googled on you know Banks tightening
up lending requirements and if you
Google on it you'll get about four pages
of results of recent news articles on
how banks are tightening Lending and I
think that that's one reason I think
somebody mentioned this earlier today
I was watching on YouTube uh that the
local Builders aren't building it's out
of state builders that are coming in and
building these multi-family projects and
I think it's because they have access to
to bigger funds of pots of money they
have more access to to loans and and to
money to build bigger projects
and I think that's how we got into this
in the first place is that Banks
tightened up lending after the 2008
housing crisis and only loan to people
with Superior Credit
Records who could buy the big mcmansions
and that's what Builders build Builders
will build what there's a market for
and the market has been for larger
houses not for Workforce housing because
people with
not so great credit or maybe just lower
incomes weren't getting the money to be
able to buy a house
so due to these many problems Builders
are not capable of meeting the need
either for single-family multi-family
rentals or townhouse and condos that
make up the middle of the market
and I understand that we need Builders
and developers to build housing I'm not
against developers but and developers
need to make a profit
but as I said they haven't been building
this housing because they can't get
financing because the buyers can't get
financing
so I think we're talking about a math
problem here it's not a complicated
algorithm it's just I think you had the
Dover Planner on who mentioned 205
dollars I'm sure everybody that stuck
with everybody right that has like 205
dollars a square foot I used to do some
building too back when it was a hundred
dollars a square foot I don't know if
anybody remembers of those days
but anyway uh
that was a much better number uh
so a builder cannot build a house for
205 a square foot plus the utilities and
the lot and sell it
to someone
for a rent or mortgage that equals 30 of
the median income
you know who's whose income is 100 of
the median in this state they it just
doesn't work it just doesn't doesn't
really work out
and that's why uh I mean right now we're
looking at private sector developers who
find and purchase the property et cetera
Etc
so
um
how are we going to dig this out I mean
zoning is important but adus are not
going to get us out of this problem
nobody's going to build enough of them
um affordable housing there are very few
avenues for potential developers to
build affordable housing and as I said
there's a fundamental disconnect
philosophically between housing as a
human right as Jessica mentioned
and I think it damages us all morally
when we see people living in motels and
on the streets and in tents and in their
cars I mean if Society exists for any
purpose at all it's to make sure the
least Among Us have what they need for a
minimal respectable existence
um
I think that only non-profit developers
can bridge the gap
with local Regional and Statewide
non-profits developing affordable and
Supportive Housing
and we're going to have to consider
financing including grants and tax
credits and towns have to designate
areas where multi-family and affordable
houses can be built
um
so
the other thing that I think you're not
sure we've talked about is using State
and County Land
recently the state released the land
from the Laconia
hospital or school and in an RFP deal
I think they actually could have done a
better deal with more affordable housing
but I think that they wrote the RFP
probably five years ago or something
but there's County Land the Hillsborough
County still has a 300 acres left over
from that the nursing home which was the
poor farm which I don't know if you've
heard about but I'm sure the other
Counties have land as well
and as far as I know they have taken no
steps at all to release any of this they
could be doing rfps
for affordable housing projects on on
that kind of land
and um
the other thing is I think you've heard
about manufactured home parks being a
part of our affordable housing
landscape here in New Hampshire
especially
I have to say I was very upset when the
guy came here and said you know
manufactured home parks just are for
those kind of people and we don't really
need them because I think new
manufactured home parks
could be a part of the solution in
different parts of the state where we
happen to have the land
and I also ran into this very
interesting situation
the other day when I was looking at
realtor.com and I set it for looking at
the lowest possible priced land or lot
that you could get in the state I don't
know if you've tried this representative
yocella but it was thirteen thousand
dollars
and I think it was probably a tenth of
an acre because there is a lot of these
little subdivisions usually around Lakes
that were subdivided in the 60s is that
right
and the problem is that they all have
restrictions which we might have called
covenants I've been trying to get a
realtor to talk to me about this and I
can't get anybody to say boo
um but they have these restrictions
about whether you can build there you
can't build there or you have to have a
septic system or you can only live there
and
in the summer and you have to take your
place off in the winter you can't live
there year round it has to be more than
a thousand square feet it can't be more
than a thousand square feet and this is
a real untapped resource I think
um you know there's a lot of young
people in the state that are graduating
from college and living in apartments
when they would rather be living or they
could be living someplace and uh and be
building some equity
and um
so I think that nobody's really
investigated that at all
I just started like last week
I think it's really an interesting
resource and to go with it I would
suggest uh
one of these companies there's one in
Maine called it's runs anyway it's
backyard Adu company and they prefab
these buildings and come in with a crane
and drop them onto your site with a very
Innovative Foundation system
and if the dec would actually allow
composting toilets you could solve your
whole
septic problem right there
that's that's I'm done thank you great
representative Wallace then
representative
um would you be surprised at composting
toilets are approved title V throughout
the country
um yeah I would be surprised what about
New Hampshire are they approved here yes
so you could actually use one here yes
yes really yes oh thank you very much
representative Conkey
thank you Mr chairman
um thoughtful conversation I appreciate
that you had mentioned Hillsborough
County was it Hillsborough County that
has 300 acres of County Land as far as I
as far as I've been able to tell yeah
really and we are working we're in the
early stages but we're working with the
town because unless it's a County
facility then you have to abide by all
of the regulations but I think we have a
willing town over a year's time with
zoning to actually come up with a
footprint that makes sense well that's
what I that's what I found out talking
to representative long Pat long as a
matter of fact that everyone who from
Hillsborough County who's in the
legislature here is on this committee
right and the same for Carroll County
who who is on the committee that governs
Hillsborough County and they have the
power to release this land I guess
well I'm really glad to hear that maybe
you could set a pattern for the rest of
the state
yeah
thank you
are there any other questions for Miss
hate representative Reed and then
representative
well I wanted to ask you um
a little bit more about
um
the county land that could be available
just sit for an instant would you
believe that Rockingham County
um our County Complex is in Brentwood
but there's no transportation out there
no well transportation and I think that
um our planning board chair
um Bryce kawo
mentioned that transportation and
housing are really like linked together
and that if you don't have
transportation you can hardly build
affordable housing but you could
Institute some kind of shuttle bus that
that served a particular piece of
property or particular subdivision or
particular
development I suppose I I don't know
maybe you guys ought to have a
transportation committee next year
special house committee on
Transportation that you would contact
the speaker
we have now four committees so I don't
know how many more special committees we
want to do
um representative thank you Mr chair
thank you for your your presentation and
I guess I'm just going to kind of
because we've talked a lot and my
colleagues know how much I love adus but
I've never said it's a Magic Bullet it
to me it's I'm excited about because
it's low hanging fruit whereas all these
other things are going to require a lot
more this seems like a no doubt but all
these other things require a lot more
thought and like money so getting to
your point because something I've said
before and I said earlier today the
issue has Isn't actually technically
housing it's affordable housing because
and this is a number that's a couple
years old now but New Hampshire as of
like I think 2020 had 74 empty homes a
lot of vacation homes
for every homeless person that they had
have we have in the state I think that
you know that number's probably changed
in the last couple years but the point
is is that getting to it being an
affordable thing right that's that's the
focus and when we're working within the
free market there's really not so much
we can do because it's not as attractive
for developers to develop things they're
not going to make as much of a profit on
and affordable housing isn't going to
get them a lot of profit in most cases
there are some like little adjustments
we can make but that's really the Crux
of the issue and so when I I hear you
speaking
the thing that I thought and like tell
me if this is what you were getting at
or if I'm completely off base is
um an idea well I'll just put this out
there what if
instead of in like what if we the state
were to actually start doing this for
people in that we develop I guess you
call it public housing it's not really
public housing because the idea is that
we would be the developer and we would
sell it and we would sell it not at
profit right and we would approve people
because we would also be the lender and
we would approve people it's almost like
Habitat for Humanity almost where we're
like I think we're I I understand you're
trying to ask this question but I think
we're looking less of government
takeover of the entire house well I know
you are I know you are
that was a question for me I have a
comment actually and my comment is that
my thought was that we set up a New
Hampshire Housing Bank that finances
housing and that we're very well set up
for that because we have New Hampshire
Finance
they're already organized all they need
is Frost in the back yeah oh I didn't
realize
well but that's kind of what I suggest
but I mean I think that that that
putting more money and I also I disagree
with you on we actually do need more
market rate housing something to the
nature of 90 000 units in the next 30 or
40 years all together and I think that
includes
some market rate housing as well but
that apparently I think it's going to be
difficult to finance that as well
so I mean I don't I'm not an expert on
Housing Finance but I mean that's what I
was kind of suggesting was in a not a
Total Takeover of the entire housing
market but the point is there are people
who are underserved and if you have a
system that is inherently not for profit
as government is then you can come in
and serve that community that is
unserved by the market forces but we
also we have also in the state a very
robust group of non-profit housing
developers that are mostly under the
neighbor works
rubric but also some others that are and
and also we're trying to start a housing
Land Trust in which we would buy the
Manchester housing Alliance Land Trust
in which we would own the property and
Lease the house on it
for 99 years
to the to the to the resident and then
the resident would be paying a mortgage
on something less than the total value
of the property and for a multi-family
house it could be a co-op that has a
Master Lease
on the building
and but the land trust would continue to
own the property which is actually sort
of the model that these Co-op
manufactured home parks operate under
and I have I have the intention of
inviting people to this committee to
discuss that as well yeah I'm the
president of land trust as well
obviously
we just started like last month so well
I want to thank you for your
presentation and if anybody has any more
questions I'm sure you're going to be
here
thank you very much thank you very much
all right so I want to move on briefly
we have about 50 45 minutes I want to
move on just to have a brief a
conversation around what we've done so
far with housing
um potential solutions that we're seeing
and maybe you know if the committee is
amicable dividing up into smaller
subcommittees to deal with certain parts
of legislation and then coming back and
presenting it to the full committee so I
kind of want to open the floor up I know
we discussed Adu I'm sure representative
Reed would love to have a group of two
or three of us to go through the Adu
language and come right back to the
committee but are there other areas of
the of this committee or presentations
that you'd like to discuss
representative Gibbs
um I guess I I still think we we have to
start with zoning
um uh financing because obviously
crucial as well but you're not going to
be able to get financing ever for
housing that you can't build because of
local regulations
um so if we're able to address zoning
and
um apparently also building codes it
seems that the the
um uh intent of the State Building Code
was to prevent
um uh
I don't know quite what what to call it
um uh local idiosyncrasies perhaps
um but it also seems from what I've been
told that there are a lot of local
idiosyncrasies out there
um and it seems like there there needs
to be some control over that
um but before we can go anywhere uh we
have to determine uh what kind of zoning
um is actually reasonable where we have
city or town Water and Sewer
um and there are clearly places
um where we have City and town Water and
Sewer that are still requiring one acre
lots
um and that's not reasonable
um and if we need to find ways to
improve Water and Sewer capacity by
impact fees or by additional State
regulation or assistance we need to look
into those things
um and then separately we need to look
into those areas that are not going to
have Town Water and Sewer anytime soon
but still need to have more sensible
zoning regulations than 20 acre lots and
I think uh what we were told before
um about uh where you have
um uh both
um an individual septic system and
individual well that the maximum needed
is probably one acre uh that was
actually larger than I had thought but
I'll be interested to hear what the
engineers have to say uh when they come
to talk to talk to us but I think
um the earlier presenter knows more
about that than I do so for the moment
I'll defer to him but
still one acre is not five acres it's
not ten acres it's not 20 acres
and so we need to look at things that
make sense and that are reasonable and
practicable because you're never going
to be able to build any kind of
affordable housing on 20 acre lots
so I that's where I I think that's where
I want to start Beyond adus which are
obviously
um a necessary component but we already
have a bill on that
um and I was going to ask representative
Reed um and maybe when I when I finish
what I'm saying I'll ask her uh I was
going to ask her um uh what she wants to
do with it now that it's been tabled
um but clearly we need to go beyond that
because adus are not going to solve the
problem by themselves
um and I do think where we have to start
with is with zoning uh and then go on to
building codes and financing
um does that make sense
representative Keller
um thank you
um
I think that the building code
um discussion is
right now we have a Statewide building
code and then local municipalities can
adopt more stringent stuff
um I think that
in a large sense that is what
representative Gibbs was talking about
as far as like being able to to to do
allow for local like adjustments
um those adjustments are already always
going to be more restrictive they can't
be less restrictive than the Statewide
and so
um I I don't see how
um
other than restricting that option to
the municipalities entirely which
I'll just from my experience I know that
one part of the municipal associations
legislative priorities is to allow more
flexibility with adopting more recent
Zone building code stuff
I don't see that that is going to be I
think that's going to be a hard sell and
so I have to agree that that zoning
um
is probably the easiest thing to and and
I think it's probably the most impactful
because I think that building codes the
building codes allow the three foot set
setback from the sides they allow all of
those types of things seem to be allowed
they're
um in the building code
they're just not allowed in the zoning
and so I think that the zoning we would
have to do a lot of trimming of the fat
of zoning before we're ever hampered by
the the limits of the building code and
so I think that that is where my focus
kind of seems to be uh kind of steering
me towards
so yeah I think I think there's some
Merit to that I think that housing
action brought up when they presented
about there's there seems to be gaps
between the written codes and then like
what's required of the town
so maybe requiring the town
be transparent about what they're
requiring ahead of time and no last
minute changes and because that's what
we run into is maybe like something's
approved by a planning board or in and
goes through the correct process and
then last minute something comes up and
said oh you actually need to do this as
well
um
I could see the possibility of getting
some some people on board to do
legislation to deal with like
no approving and then taking it back
subject to another thing
so
representative Wallace thank you Mr
chairman yes uh I've said before that um
you know a bill such that no political
subdivision may require any further
requirements be it zoning or licensing
requirements
that are in place at the time of
issuance of the building permit for the
property being developed we've heard
multiple presenters early on saying that
they've gone to town X they've got a
permit with conditions 1 through 37
they've complied with all those they go
for their occupancy permits or
inspections along the way well I know we
asked these 37 things well here's
another 17 that we needed to comply yes
it's not in statute but really we'd
really like that down if you want that
CEOs or a man so uh to that extent
you're not going to get cooperation from
the towns that have the 20-acre zoning a
minimum
20 acre requirements for building lot to
work with the cities that know they have
the problems that are doing wonderful
things thus far to minimize this problem
so you've got your you know they're not
in my backyard we don't want we don't
want these um
affordable housing units and we know who
the towns are let's face it um
so I think you're going to need to have
some type of Statewide preemption to say
hey these are the rules in place when
the game started no new rules until that
game is over uh the build you know next
project we'll talk about it so something
to that extent
um it follows with what representative
gibbs's suggestion suggested
representative Gibbs uh yes it does
um and in reference to what uh
representative yokolo was was saying um
I agree we have to start zoning that was
what I said in the first place uh we do
uh because you're never going to get
anywhere if if zoning prevents you from
doing something but then
um
the building code issue comes up just
exactly as representative Wallace has
described from what we've heard
repeatedly and from what I've heard
individually as well uh that
you have something on the books and then
somebody
um and again I don't want to get any
videos here but it seems frequently to
be the fire commissioner uh comes back
and says well
we really needed to do X Y and Z in
addition to what we already told you and
in addition to what's actually on the
books before we can actually give you an
occupancy permit and that obviously uh
does two things one is it tremendously
increases the amount of time and uh both
in and of itself and in terms of the
amount of time it takes it increases the
expense
um and if people are aware that this is
happening
um there are some places that I would
imagine developers simply won't go
because they know it's going to be
impossible
um or they'll get to a certain point
they'll just throw up their hands in in
despair uh and that's that's not what we
want that's not going to solve the
problem that we have in New Hampshire uh
with regard to housing in general or
with regard to affordable housing so at
some point we're going to have to say
okay we have some flexibility for local
needs but you can be more stringent in
the state code only up to this point
um and perhaps
um you know if if you tell uh the
developer that they have to do these 30
37 things you cannot then come back uh
at the occupancy permit uh stage or
whatever the later stages are and say
okay now we're going to add you know
three or four six more more items and
have it become impossible
um so yes I want to start with zoning
but I think we also have to be aware
that these other issues are going to
come next
is that fair that's fair representative
Reed
so yeah on that so the what
representative Wallace was describing is
kind of like the headaches that
developers face
but then there's also like the initial
zoning of like lot minimums I think
we've identified lot minimums as a
primary
um problem in in the zoning World in
terms of of solving the housing crisis
so what I would like to see again going
back to that presentation a couple weeks
ago where you know we talked about how
they even got started
um is clarification in law that
Municipal ordinances have to be based
evidence-based evidence-backed for the
health safety and Welfare of the people
and like we can even get into more
detail about what that means so that
we're getting away from those arbitrary
um this is kind of like what we want our
community to look like and we don't want
those people in this community kind of
ordinances
um so I think we can kind of have a
broad statement saying it has the
ordinance is half to adhere to this
broad principle of health safety and
Welfare as we're defining it and then
also get into and therefore this is how
lot minimum shall be determined
um and there's some other stuff too like
square foot minimums um we've we've
listed quite a few but I think those two
in particular are important there's also
the other end of it which is the you
know the the buyer and the financing and
this is actually from mercatus
that and this does touch on adus and I
don't think adus are a Magic Bullet but
I do think it's a low hanging fruit but
it also touches on General financing
otherwise whereas people are running
into financing problems
when because the banks do not consider
the income that they can receive from
that property and so obviously Adu
income rental income from Adu is
something that a bank should be I think
um taking into account when they're you
know questioning whether or not to
approve somebody for that and that's
been a major barrier for people to buy
properties that they would be able to
afford because that property has income
so that I think that's something else
that we can look at
McConkey did you have something please
go ahead
so I I would totally agree that if there
was language that could address that
when a when a homeowner or developer
starts a process and pulls his permits
that
there's you know there's an end point to
that as long as considered and there
wasn't a fault Tom had a bill with the
issue on someone had already built uh
to the town standard and all of a sudden
the driveway has to be six feet wider I
mean that's you know if we can get
language it does that zoning zoning is I
don't know if you're looking to come out
of here with zoning suggestions because
I don't see that happening real quickly
but I think I think we could develop
some models for consideration and we
could make people aware of that could be
a finding out of here instead of a
instead of an order page this is what we
came to I mean there is truly some
Innovative things being done in Dover
some of the micro stuff in Manchester
New Market I think if we were to
highlight those things and make a goal
of an ongoing committee on another time
I think that would be a laudable goal
and if we can if we can find some other
items as recommendations but we know we
know that as the gentleman had talked
about lot size
being not determined by today's standard
I mean that's that's certainly and I I
think you were talking about continuing
the conversation so I think we should
bring and if you
that was going to be the next but
not not the top I want some people in
here that work in the field and I could
help those suggestions on that and have
we had someone
um
I guess we we've skirted and we've
talked about manufactured housing
I didn't know if we there was any need
to have any more on that that's that's
also my plan is to invite some even for
that we're on it you're on it Mr
chairman all right I I think right
before I recognize you I think that
that's a good idea to put together maybe
um
not necessarily in legislation but get
the researcher to put together like
model policies from places like towns
that have done you know thinking Dover
like what if their policies look like
that have enabled them to put together
the cottages on Back River Road for
instance
um and put that together in almost a
booklet or something that we can
distribute or have the municipal
Association during their training
um distribute all these policies to
local planning and zoning boards so they
kind of know creative ideas if they're
interested in pursuing those and I might
suggest that and what we're going to try
and do in Osprey in Carroll County is
our proposal is probably going to start
out with an overlay District in a town
and if it works there then like everyone
said in the future you can expand you
can expand it's a it's a softer way to
get to town to possibly do what you need
to do
representative Walsh
thank you apologize for my uh my attire
uh but I was at work listening to the
proceedings this morning on YouTube the
whole time it was great
um I take it because I was out of the
room for a minute but we were just
looking at the way to move forward at
this point all right I'll start by
saying the first day we were here uh I'm
not one that's going to support state
mandated zoning around to our towns I
can't do it I do like representative
mcconkey's suggestion about some zoning
models I think that's a great idea I
also have a funny feeling that the towns
aren't stupid either and you we've
already heard of a lot of them that are
actually starting to make the moves
towards improving on their own and I
think that's the way it should happen I
know zoning bugs some people I know it
bugs maritas I know it bugs Jason sworns
I know it bugs a lot of people but I
haven't heard anybody sit at that table
and tell me that that's the drop dead
problem that we're having with the
housing crisis
person after person after person and I
recommend getting on Senate Bill 78 so
we can get those people here because
they both claim to build houses
affordable housing I say it's cost
a lot of this cost we may not have
anything to do with but there may be
some things that we can looking at the
zoning I mean uh the codes fire codes
etc etc
um
but again I'm not to mandate zoning on
the town side I would never be able to
support I do have a question though 20
acre who's got 28 or minimums
we I I the zoning Atlas we put a 20 acre
minimum in it and I think it popped up a
little in the north plate because here's
the thing even if some towns have 5 10
20 acre
minimums I have a funny feeling they're
not going to have much of a demand for
affordable housing complexes anyway
they're the rural communities that want
to stay Rural and you know what any any
type of zoning change is going to be a
hard sell because
okay I mean we have to admit some of
these ordinants are probably put in
place to limit density by Design
and you know what I don't blame them I
mean I'm from Hooksett we have
voluntarily expanded our density when I
moved there in 78 we were 3 400 people
now we're pushing sixteen thousand we've
done it ourselves but now I represent
Dunbarton and I don't see them wanting
16 000 people in Denver nor am I going
to go there and say hey we know better
than you you should so I I I I don't
even think that's the direction we
should be looking at
um again I don't think the demand is
there for them and and I
um I'm one of the few natives I guess
left in this legislature New Hampshire
right but
I for those that think zoning is the way
to go to increase that density across
the board
um mandated uh from rural communities to
to suburbs take a ride down Route 128
Massachusetts please and get off the
highway in in Waltham Western in that
whole area 25 years ago that was as
rural as New Hampshire is take a ride
down there now it is gridlock
pandemonium it's awful and if that's the
goal you have for New Hampshire then I
suggest we start going after our Town's
local zoning it's not my goal
so I'll leave it at that I think we've
got some constructive things to look at
but for me zoning isn't one of them
thank you so yeah and so thank you so
what what I understand that
representative Wallace's language and
final approval something that like that
you'd be on board with
um and then you know a model model
policies free municipalities no mandates
but like a packet of model policies for
them okay and I really think we should
get those people I don't know if we'll
have time maybe we can check the docket
from 78 it was a municipal County and
get those two affordable housing
developers in here uh the whole premise
of the affordable of House Bill 78 which
we might be able to embrace we can talk
to the chair uh it also talks about more
costs which are Surety bonds right now
you have Surety bonds for our for
landscaping for roadways Etc et cetera
but yet all these things are constructed
with the supervision and Engineering
paid for by the developer insisted upon
by the town so what do they need to bond
locked up in the bank for for six ten
years you know none of this stuff makes
any sense so and I heard the
conversation earlier about lengthening
the time we we let them hold on to bond
money um or even impact fees that's
going in the opposite direction I
thought that cost is going to get passed
on down to the consumer again one last
thing on impact fees that I did here in
the conversation this morning something
else I think we can look at I believe
there's only 14 towns in New Hampshire
that impose impact fees
got a 234 that's not many books it
happens to be one of them
but the they're pretty specific and a
lot of times
the money should get returned to the
developers but they always seem to find
a way that's not really related that
they find a way to spend the money on
so impact fees could be looked at as a
way to save some money
okay representative thank you Mr
chairman I just want to follow up with
uh
representative Walsh you know I've done
some work in a lot of different
communities we've heard some from some
good people who are aggressive
especially people towards the Seacoast
they're your planning boards are very
aggressive I go to a marketing session
Dover would show up and say come on in
you know then you have the towns that
don't want you there
I've dealt with them
I had a project that took me over 14
months to get approved halfway through
the process they went from three acres
zoning to five acres only because they
didn't want it was the first cluster
Zone development in the town it was it
was on for it they just didn't want it
and they did everything they could to
stop us from getting it you have those
towns and I can name a half a dozen
towns where I have personal experience
where they don't want any growth
and to you know like to follow up with
uh representative wall should to impose
restrictions on on some of these towns
will there meet with a lot of resistance
and uh
it's unfortunate we need it
people are going out on the street
no housing
it's a it's a crisis and we're in a
between a rock and a high place but
we've got to be careful on what we want
to put forward because half of it won't
go anywhere I don't think and I've also
had
people in the middle would go through
the punch list and all of a sudden
there's more popping up in fire
departments are number one on my list
fire departments and wetlands people
conservation okay representative Ocala
then Representatives
um I think you know from from everything
that I've said that I'm adamantly
um in favor of limiting the
um overreach of zoning I think that
it is inappropriate for
for under the guise of health and safety
to be
um Central planning your
um your municipality into only the
people that currently live there
um and
I also
um I think that that zoning is
um an ability that the state gave to
those local municipalities and it can
place strings on that ability that it
that it gave to those municipalities and
it is not any overreach it is just
recognizing that sometimes we gave them
too much latitude and they abuse that
Latitude I think that
um
one of the things that I I like the idea
of kind of having
like model zoning or something like that
that is something that is
um good something to strive for and and
um
maybe and and I think I've expressed to
the the chair before about my concern
about the housing Champion
um
legislation going through the Senate and
that I I want to see some like they're
talking about money being offered to
municipalities
um if they're you know a housing
Champion or what and and that there
needs to be stringent kind of goal posts
that they need to actually like move the
ball forward and not just stay in the
status quo if they are needing to or if
they're going to have the ability to get
any uh assistance from the from the
state and so I have a lot of concerns
that that maybe they would already
um you know qualify at the level that
they are that they are currently you
know restricting people
so I think that you know there's I'm I'm
happy with you know absolutely coming in
and saying you as a state statement
Statewide zoning requirement you are not
allowed to have a minimum house size
requirement
I understand that right now under the
building code you can only reach 200
square feet but if that changes I don't
think we need to have additional
legislation I think that we can just say
no
um square foot requirements in your
zoning it's not a it's a Statewide
mandate and it's a reasonable one we
already have we already have
um you know property or we already have
building code that can address those
size
um
opportunities
or size requirements and that I don't
think that is unreasonable I think that
you can have wide support about stuff
like that
um maybe not from not Universal support
from you know staunch like people that
think that that that municipality should
be able to do whatever they want but I
think most reasonable people are going
to be able to vote in support of stuff
stuff like that
um I I do like the idea of having some
goals like if you do this if you you
know put legislation that allows this
type of thing and um then we're going to
recognize you as a housing Champion or
something like that where we're going to
offer different opportunities or
incentives for that and I definitely
agree that if we're when we're con
considering
opportunities either through the funding
um either I don't know low interest
loans or whatever so that they can have
sewer and water expand sewer and water
that we have time we have strings
attached to that to say that you have to
have increased density when you're
putting in water and sewer it's it's
unreasonable investment of your money to
put
um all of this infrastructure in and
then have like five people be able to
use it when 40 people could it's just
bad investment for the state and so I
think that we should have all of those
um strings attached and and and
responding as I said to to your comment
um earlier today
about how the um
the bills or or amendments that we
propose go to their
um you know traditional
committees I think that this committee
has spent an enormous amount of time
getting to become experts on this issue
and that I don't think that it is is
possible to convey that amount of
expertise in a com in a traditional
Committee hearing and so I definitely
would be in favor of the chair or the
speaker
designating some things that we are now
kind of the resident experts in the in
the house to be
um
uh addressing that topic you know more
thoroughly if he wants to add a second
committee to it that's that's obviously
within the speaker's prerogative but I
definitely think that it would be a
disservice to not utilize the expertise
that was gained in this committee you
know spending all this time in here
thank you
um I do think a lot of what we've been
talking about is going to be a hard sell
um I'm not minimizing the difficulties
um but
there are a couple things
um one thing is that um personally
um I could support some things that
wouldn't make me personally feel really
happy in order to know that never again
uh will there be a family with children
living in a car in New Hampshire in the
winter which has happened
um so that is something that I feel very
strongly about and there are things that
I would give up to be sure of that
um but then going beyond that
um we need to respect the
um uh feelings and opinions of people
who have lived in a rural community uh
for a long time I'm not minimizing that
either I grew up on a farm uh in New
Jersey uh and the area was extremely
rural when I was a child and it began to
change during my childhood and now where
my family's 150 year old farmhouse stood
there is no now a pink stucco minimal is
the ugliest thing I have ever seen in my
entire life
um that
isn't what I want anywhere
um but I don't run the world uh and none
of us do and we have to keep our eye on
the ball in terms of what our goals are
um and I think our major goal has to be
more affordable housing
um
so we have to find creative ways to
balance the needs of existing
communities and I'm not saying that we
should discount the needs of existing
communities and the needs of
young people with families uh the needs
of older people who can no longer afford
where they've been living which we heard
about uh just this morning
um and that was quite heartbreaking
somebody whose rent was 900 a month and
now it's going to be eighteen hundred
dollars a month and they have to move
but they have nowhere to move to
um and that's where I think that as I
suggested to the
um uh planning board director uh that
the city needs to look into working with
non-profits in applying for federal
grants because that opportunity
certainly has existed in the past and I
believe still exists again I'm more of
an expert on on what was in existence
before I retired than what I am now uh
but there are creative ways to to
approach these things some of them are
going to require I think more mandates
than some of us would really like
um but some of that is going is going to
be necessary it's going to be
unavoidable
um and I I don't think we can we can
entirely stop it but we need to find
creative ways to
balance the needs of the various
stakeholders
um and this is doable I think I've
mentioned earlier that when I started
working at HUD
um we would see developments with two or
three
um investment participants by the time I
left most of the projects had a dozen
um and we were balancing the needs of a
dozen stakeholders but at least quite a
few of those projects didn't move
forward it is possible to do and I think
it is something that we need to do I I
still think we need to start with zoning
um but then looking looking forward on
other things and
we need to consider everybody's feelings
not just the feelings of the people who
are currently there
um but uh for instance people who may be
moving from Massachusetts or who knows
where
um to work in New Hampshire uh because
they need jobs and they need places to
live and the businesses that are trying
to hire them need workers they need
workers desperately we all know this
um so we have to put all of that
together and not just say
um well we'd rather not do X
um there are things I'd rather not do
either I wish I could get rid of that
pink stucco many more
um but we have to consider uh what's
best for the state as a whole thing
thank you Mr chair
so I want to preface this by saying my
dream has always been now for 20 years
to have a farm
um my family is always rented I've
always rented I don't know anybody who
owns a home in my family I've never
owned a home it's always been the dream
I am deeply personally offended
whenever I hear anyone and I don't mean
just comments today
because I've heard it for many years
that
this is how we want our community to
look we don't want those types of people
we don't and and that we do this because
we bought our home
10 20 30 40 50 years ago
when the price of that home was one year
of a median income single person median
income
I I will say I doubt that there's
anybody here maybe even alive that
remembers a time that housing has
increased so much in terms of cost we
just heard doubling of rents in my
community it's been tripling over the
last few years just three years ago a
two bedroom was 800 a two bedroom in
Newmarket now is 200 2 400 we had a
whole building go from 725 to 1750 in a
month because of a change of ownership
so I I get deeply offended when I'm
being told by people who may have bought
their homes 40 years ago when it was
super affordable that we want to
increase and make it inaccessible to buy
any land here to buy a home here because
we want it to stay the way it's going
well you know what populations change
populations grow
I feel excluded I feel like my needs
don't count as a person I mean I live in
a 700 square foot apartment and I still
dream of having a little farm but that
dream apparently isn't allowed to me
because the people who got lucky by
being born at the right time
got in when it was good and went to set
up the balls so that nobody else can
come in
so I get deeply hurt when I hear those
kinds of comments I find it elitist and
I find it to be the exact kind of
thinking that has got us to the
situation today that we are in in the
housing crisis that we are in
so I don't think that kind of thinking
is going to get us out of it so that's
what I have to say
okay
great uh representative Damon
I just want to say that I don't think we
have clearly enough
identified in our work that we need to
look at the money
so
agree that the adus are low-hanging
fruit yes let's make that happen better
yes there are zoning approaches
to be dialogued and considered
but the issue of
how do we incentivize non-profit
developers or others
to make these structures happen I think
we have to do work on that
um
that's all
okay
representative McConkey
just pop your microphone on for us
please
I'm somewhat confused by the
conversation because I missed this
morning and I I haven't heard used guys
aren't allowed here
um it is never
I'm fortunate that I live on a lake
I worked hard for a number of years sold
my sold my business and I moved to a
lake
but I also know that the family is owned
a cottage on Barnstead lake for 40 years
Barnstead Lake was never in the reach of
an average person
and a house is always a struggle for a
person no matter what snapshot in time
you look at
so I I take someone I I love the fact
that you would like to live on a farm I
totally understand that I like that and
people should have
availability but
housing
for most people is always a struggle and
how and how they're going to be able to
afford to do that
I've sat here with a lot of knowledge
the government spent a lot of time on me
and educated me in Zoning for my town
because we had no Zone the Lincoln
Institute I could go on and on a
wonderful wonderful think tanks I've
attended but I sat here one year and
heard we're going to put a bill in that
is going to have five units on every law
I knew that was good
so what do we do in the following year
we say four units is the right number
and I'm sitting there telling the people
around me I can guarantee it's going to
be three next year
so
um there's a lot to be said
for this gentleman's view that I live in
a town and you're not going to tell me
what to do
so I I think we need to find that mix of
helping them I've I've been a lot of
towns that have no idea when I when I
told them what's happening in Dover
their eyes just opened up they just had
no idea and that's literally just down
the road from where I'm at so
I'm hoping we can do a primer I'm more
than willing to work on that next step
that's awesome
representative Wallace
full disclosure I didn't buy my house
until 2005 just before the crash and I
lost all my Equity Now it only needs a
hundred thousand dollars worth of
repairs so it's not all it's cracked up
to be
um but on a positive note and on an
encouraging side
um as I said before supply and demand
where these units need to be where does
where are we short there was a study I
saw not too long ago and I mentioned
this on day one but this I'm mentioning
it again today just so we have a
Direction
is that the majority of the communities
in
South Central New Hampshire leading all
the way up to Concord actually grew two
to three hundred percent for their
housing inventory except Nashua
Manchester and Concord they grew at
about 40 percent so I was encouraged to
hear Manchester's planning department
here today and they are making some
strides because they are knocking down
building after building and increasing
their their inventory at a much greater
rate
it's unfortunate they didn't keep up the
same rate as the rest of Southern New
Hampshire because we probably wouldn't
be in the situation we're in right now
we're at least not as bad so there is
still encouraging things and it goes
back to my proof that the communities
and everybody who can see what's going
on here uh they're all going to start
working on it on their own and already
are so
thank you okay
um so as somebody who has to go bartend
later I'm gonna try to wrap this up so
um action items
representative Wallace can you send us
language for your
um preemptive bill please
um representative Reed can you get us
some language maybe on 423 that can add
some parking
I'd like to see some parking language on
there and then send it to the committee
um I'm going to reach out to the
committee researcher it's like hello
um
we want to put together some model
policies
um so we want to put together some maybe
reach out to Dover New Market some of
these places from our committee that
we've found success and maybe put
together
some policies that we would recommend
but not mandate
um and then I would also like to see the
towns that do require impact fees uh
what that looks like and um
their policies around those
is there anything
and I will speak to Senator Innis
regarding Senate Bill 78. Alyssa are you
familiar with those developers can we
talk about that offline okay
perfect so Alyssa is probably
coordinating their non-profit developers
right on the bill
home builders Bill okay so I'll I'll
connect with Alyssa regarding that bill
I haven't had a chance to read it since
you emailed me but I'm definitely
looking forward to doing that
okay and is there anything else uh so
should we plan on the next meeting being
May 15th and I will try to invite
um the Human Rights Commission and
um someone from the
um uh HUD uh either either the regional
administrator's office or the Manchester
office uh for the for uh May 15th yes
um could you
give me a time I would like to put that
into a a block of time so when you when
they give you availability let me know
as soon as possible so I can
get them scheduled I will hopefully they
will be available on that day thank you
representative Rudy's gonna reach up
some people I'm going to reach out to
Des and get them here for that date as
well so let's um let's plan on May 15th
do like almost a full day
um yep and once you get in touch with
your people let me know and I'll go
ahead and I request when you reach out
to manufactured housing
I specialist I was unclear if you meant
manufacture housing Specialists or
specifically co-ops we get co-ops okay
I'm gonna get somebody from a co-op
coming
are you going to continue to schedule
work sessions as part of the at the end
of the day going forward I think there I
think think they're productive to kind
of see where we're at after the
presentation sure
representative
so I just want to
Saturday make
by vital communities vital communities
is a non-profit that buses the River
from Hanover to Vermont they do all
kinds of really wonderful programming
and this Workshop is called the how to's
about adus so it's on the sixth it's
from ten to three I believe it's free
and if you just go to
vitalcommunities.org it is there is a
agenda and registration their programs
are usually very well done
representative Wall Street yeah another
comment too maybe Mr Frost knows about
it I know Hooksett had requested a
housing needs assessment
um I don't know how many other
communities did but I know ours is ready
so we'll be hearing it soon so there may
be more information around the corner
great
thank you well everyone have a great day
we're adjourned for the day thank you